Nächste Woche.
Chaos Radio 102 habt ihr eingeschaltet auf Fritz. Raumberuf Hacker? Fragezeichen ist das Thema. Ich glaube, wir müssen mit einer Begriffsbestimmung anfangen, Frank, oder?
Was Hacker ist?
Nun, Hacker drängen in private und behördliche Computersysteme ein und verursachen einen Chaos. Sie infizieren sie mit Viren und stehlen Material, das sie dann für ihre eigenen Zwecke verwenden. Diese Leute sind Terroristen.
Terroristen alles hier. Genau. Wir wollen aber heute eigentlich mehr über den professionellen Hacker sprechen. Deswegen heißt die Sendung Traumberuf Hacker Fragezeichen und diese Leute, die sowas machen, heißen richtig Security Consultants und das sind Leute, die im Prinzip bezahlt, also als ihren Beruf in Systeme eindringen oder versuchen Schwachstellen in Systemen aufzudecken und aber auch technische Geräte wie zum Beispiel Software Handys analysieren, wo da Schwachstellen sind und da für den Auftraggeber entsprechende Analyse zu machen, wo da Probleme sind, was man vielleicht verbessern könnte und wo es die Gefahren liegen.
Zwei von den Leuten haben wir hier. Stellt euch selbst vor.
Ja, Thorsten, heiß Icke und ich arbeite sozusagen als professioneller Hacker freiberuflich und werde hoffentlich hier heute noch ein bisschen was dazu erzählen können.
Felix Lündner von der Enron's GmbH, auch bekannt als FX, Senior Security Consultant und macht das ungefähr seit sieben Jahren.
Professionell in Firmen, Netzwerke.
Was ich genau mache, erzählen wir glaube ich.
Das erzählen wir, okay. Ansonsten gehen wir klauen und sagen hinterher Bescheid, wo die Sparstellen sind. Wer was zu sagen hat, wird selbstverständlich auch gehört. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Nicht das erste Mal, dass Orbitle hier abends nach 10 Uhr läuft. Hockey on and on and on. Hier ist Chaos Radio 102, Traumberuf Hacker? Ist das Thema. Aber bevor wir in Medias Res oder Res Medias auf jeden Fall einsteigen ins Programm, hätten wir noch einen anderen Programm. Punkt. Und zudem begrüßen wir Tim Pridler.
Hallo Tim. Der Chaos Computer Club macht nämlich auch noch... Holger.
Der macht nämlich auch noch Geräusche. Entschuldigung, ich bin hier mit dem Arm hängen.
Wir möchten euch nämlich hinweisen auf eine Veranstaltung, wo der Chaos Computer Club auch maßgeblich beteiligt ist. Das ist nämlich die Berlin 05. Innerhalb des Projekt P findet in der Wohlheide statt, am Wochenende um den 10. Juni rum. Und da hat der Tim von uns auch noch ein paar Hinweise und möchten euch ein bisschen dieser Verschmattung machen. Ja, Intiderwissen ermitteln.
Wir haben noch eine weitere Abkürzung, also den Namen. Camp Discordia, so heißt unsere kleine Veranstaltung, die halt stattfindet auf diesem Berlin 05 genannten Event. Findet vom 10. bis zum 12. Juni statt hier in Berlin, und zwar im FEZ in der Wohlheide, in diesem riesigen Gelände. Und da wird so allerlei Tamtam aufgefahren. Das Ganze ist organisiert von der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung und wir stellen da halt sozusagen ein eigenes Dorf, das wir Camp Discordia genannt haben. Und dort machen wir ein eigenes Vortragsprogramm, sind noch mit ein paar Workshopzelten am Start und machen es uns da im Wesentlichen gemütlich.
Wer kann dahin kommen?
Ja, also geladen, also im Wesentlichen wenden tut sich die Veranstaltung an 14- bis 21-Jährige, das ist so die offiziell genannte Zielgruppe. Da sind halt, es geht halt um politische Bildung im weiteren Sinne. Auf dieser Veranstaltung geht es unter anderem aber auch einfach um den Spaß da sind irgendwie Musikgruppen gelandet, Tocotronic, Fantastische Vier, Tocotronic und Spaß, ich vergesse mal irgendjemanden, der auch noch erwähnenswert wäre, Klee, solche Sachen finden da statt. Aber im Wesentlichen geht es halt darum, so an Workshops teilzunehmen. Das heißt, es sind sehr viele Gruppen, die dort ihr eigenes Angebot pflegen, darüber wissen wir im Detail jetzt auch gar nicht so viel. Tatsache ist, wir sind halt auch da und wollen halt unsere Themen vermitteln in einem zweitägigen Vortragsprogramm, dreitägigen Vortragsprogramm, fangen wir schon früh an. Wo wir halt über Wachungsstaat, über gesetzliche Regelungen, aber auch so über Internet im Allgemeinen.
Über MP3s und tauschen im Internet.
Genau, falsch an diesem Thema. Also im Prinzip alles, was auch gerade wirklich so die heißen Eisen sind und die eigentlich auch so Jugendliche im Besonderen betreffen, einerseits weil es halt ihr Thema ist oder andererseits weil es ihr Thema sein sollte.
Gibt es eine Webseite dazu?
Gibt es. Wir veröffentlichen unseren Kram unter berlin05.ccc.de. Da haben wir im Prinzip zwei Sachen, nämlich einerseits ein Weblog, was immer so aktuelle Meldungen jetzt in den nächsten Wochen noch mit raus werfen wird und ein Wiki, wo alle wichtigen Informationen drinstehen. Da kann halt auch jeder gleich mitarbeiten, wenn er sich dazu berufen fühlt. Da findet man dann eben auch die Links auf die ganzen offiziellen Webseiten. Das ist im Wesentlichen unter berlin05.de. Also mit dem CCC dazwischen ist es sozusagen unser Kram. Und ohne CCC ist es halt alles andere, was da stattfindet. Es gibt für Leute von außerhalb ganz interessante Angebote. Man kann für 29 Euro sich ein Ticket bei der Bahn holen und dann schon überall aus Deutschland anreisen, also hin und zurück, also recht günstig. Ja, und wir würden uns einfach freuen, wenn möglichst viele da hinkommen. Da haben sich also schon viele tausend angesagt. Also es wird ein Großereignis, keine Ahnung. 5.000, die Zahlen drehen sich so ein bisschen. Und ja, wir haben halt so unseren gemütlichen Teil dort. Wir haben noch zwei Workshop-Cells, die noch erwähnenswert. Einerseits haben wir die Wikipedia-Gemeinde so bei uns, die halt so in der Einführung in Wikiarbeit und technische und soziale Aspekte von der Wikipedia mitbringt. Und auch sehr interessant, die Kunstsportgruppe Umgehungstechnik gibt sich ein Stell dich ein und macht halt Lockpicking-Workshops.
Kunstsportgruppe Umgehungstechnik, hieß sie früher nicht mal anders?
Nein, das ist, du meinst jetzt was anderes, aber das ist die Kunstsportgruppe Umgehungstechnik, die ja auch in Berlin angesiedelt ist. Die waren auch schon auf dem Kongress. Du meinst die Sportsfreunden der Sperrtechnik. So ein bisschen wie mit der Palästinensischen Volkskommission und der Volkskommission von Judea. Ja, das ist eigentlich das, was man dazu sagen kann. Wir uns alle freuen, wenn ihr dabei seid. Und um nochmal ein bisschen in die Ferne zu blicken, ein paar Wochen später gibt es noch eine andere coole Veranstaltung, und zwar Ende Juli in Holland, das What the Hack, internationale Hacker Festival Open Air, so ähnlich wie das Camp, was wir vor zwei Jahren gemacht haben, jetzt sind die Holländer wieder an der Reihe und da werden auch viele tausend Leute hinkommen und das ist noch viel spannender. Aber da werden wir natürlich in der nächsten Chaosradio Sendung auch noch einiges erzählen.
Da gab es gerade Probleme mit dem Bürgermeister, der es nicht zulassen wollte, dass es stattfindet. Hat sich das geklärt mittlerweile?
Ja, geklärt hat es sich noch nicht. Das geht jetzt gerade so eine etwas hitzigere juristische Phase, weil er da noch ein bisschen bockig ist. Aber wir sind eigentlich alle ganz zuversichtlich, dass das nicht Bestand haben kann, weil seine Vorhaltung, die Veranstaltung, also eine friedliche, gemütliche Zeltveranstaltung, wo Leute Vorträgen lauschen, würde die öffentliche Sicherheit gefährden. Und das ist natürlich nun wirklich albern.
Alles Terroristen.
Ja, in Holland hat da mittlerweile eine paraneue Einzug gehalten, die wir schwer nachvollziehen können. Früher dachten wir immer, das wäre irgendwie andersrum. Die Holländer wären entspannt und wir eigentlich nicht. Das hat sich ein bisschen umgedreht. Aber das ist unvermeidlich, dass diese Veranstaltungen stattfinden würden. Von daher kann da auch schon mal jemand wieder planen.
Ich denke, dass sich das bald lösen wird.
Berlin 05 im FIZ in der Wuhlheide vom 10. bis 12.06.
10.
bis 12.
Genau.
Und what the heck war Datum?
Das ist das letzte Juli-Wochenende. Ich habe nicht fest 27. bis 30.
Ja, aber kann man sagen.
Auf jeden Fall. Und Eintritt ist bei der Berlin 05 glaube ich 15 Euro.
Aber inklusive der Konzert auch am Abend?
Ja, inklusive von allem und irgendwelche komischen Verpflegungsregelungen gibt es da noch, die ich im Detail nicht genau kenne, aber das kriegt ihr alles raus auf der Berlin 05 Webseite und wie gesagt, wenn ihr an unserem Programm Interesse habt, www.berlin05.ccc.de.
Chaos Radio 102 auf Ritz.
Wir wollen uns heute beschäftigen mit den professionellen Aspekten des Thema Hacking. So eine Leute heißen den Security Consultants und stecken ihre Nasen und Finger, was auch immer, ganz tief in irgendwelche Computersysteme, in Stücke von Software und schauen nach, ob sie da irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken finden oder irgendwelche Sachen, die sonst für den Einsatz, also gegen den Einsatz von einer Software oder von System sprechen könnten. Was genau für System überprüft ihr da, FX? Kannst du ein bisschen erzählen, was sind so die typischen Sachen, wo ihr euch da was anschaut?
Also es gibt eigentlich so zwei Kernbereiche, die gewöhnlich betrachtet werden. Das ist einmal so Gesamtnetze. Die klassische Frage, kommt ein Hacker in mein Netz rein, wird dann gesagt, ja, lieber Hacker oder lieber Security Consultant, nimm dir mal hier einen Internetanschluss und versuch mal bei uns einzubrechen. Das nennt sich dann ein Penetration Test. Eine Seite ist das, was am häufigsten gemacht wird. Die andere Seite ist sogenannte Produkt Audits. Das heißt, man nimmt sich ein dediziertes Stück Software, Hardware, Kombination, schaut sich das im Detail an und macht dann dazu Aussagen.
Sag mal ein Beispiel, was ist da so ein, also konkret, muss jetzt ohne Firmenname oder so was, aber vielleicht ein konkretes Stück Software, also System, eine Bank oder so zum Beispiel oder was ist das denn? Oder ein spezieller Teil einer Bank oder, kannst du mal beschreiben, wie so ein Projekt aussieht, was ihr, wie das oder wie die rangehensweise dabei ist oder?
Also ich denke die Netzwerk-Penetration-Tests, das wird dann der TRS noch ein bisschen genauer erklären, wie das abläuft. Bei den Produkt-Tests ist es gewöhnlich wirklich ein abgeschlossenes Teil, also das kann sein ein Server, das kann sein ein Mobiltelefon, das kann sein ein Router, alles was irgendwie irgendwas mit Computern zu tun hat.
Das heißt also ihr kriegt das Gerät so in die Hand, wie es der normale Nutzer da draußen auch kriegen würde, also sprich ohne Dokumentation, ohne Bedienungsanleitung, ohne Quellcode für die Software, sondern einfach kriegt das Gerät in die Hand oder den Server vorgesetzt und sagt jetzt hackt mal.
Oh das hängt sehr stark davon ab, wer uns beauftragt. Also wenn es der Hersteller selber ist, dann bekommen wir natürlich ein bisschen mehr Informationen als wenn es irgendwer ist, der sich dafür interessiert.
Wir haben gerade gehört, was so typische Systeme sind oder was für Sachen sich die beiden anschauen. Kannst du vielleicht im THS nochmal ein paar mehr Beispiele bringen, also dass es ein bisschen anschaulicher wird. Das heißt, genau wie geht man da ran? Ich krieg jetzt ein Webportal. Wie ist denn die Vorgehensweise? Wie ist denn so die Rangehensweise?
Na ja, man kann schon sagen, dass eigentlich das Wichtigste bei so einem Penetrationstest ist, also was jetzt auch Web-Applikationen und das gesamte Netzwerk angeht, dass das Wichtigste daran ist, so viel Informationen wie möglich zu sammeln. Also Informationen über aktive Dienste im Netzwerk auf dem System. Da wird natürlich als erstes halt auch ein Portscan gemacht. Also es wird ermittelt, was für Dienste auf dem System aktiv sind. Dann kann man da schon mal gucken, ob es da bekannte oder auch nicht bekannte Sicherheitslücken gibt in der Software, die da aktiv ist. Ja, dann wird halt geguckt, ob es irgendwelche Dienste gibt, die Informationen preisgeben, die vielleicht nicht unbedingt preisgegeben werden sollten über Betriebssystem, Betriebssystem, Version und so weiter. Ja, und dann halt ganz speziell bei Applikationstest halt auch wird halt geguckt Standardinstallation von Softwarekomponenten, ob es da eben Skripte oder sonst was gibt, die Aufschluss über ganz viele Details gibt, die halt auch weiterhelfen.
Zum Beispiel mal Windows, kennt jeder was, was wären da so Sachen, die euch sofort aufstoßen würden, bei einer Standardinstallation von Windows?
Na ja, also dann guckt man vielleicht auch mal, ob das ordentlich gepatcht ist.
Das heißt, dass Updates eingespielt sind?
Das ist meistens der Fall, also sonst werden die Systeme natürlich innerhalb von Minutenhops genommen von irgendwelchen anderen Würmern oder so, die da so rumgeistern oder irgendwelche anderen Leute.
Die Rangehensweise, die ihr jetzt macht als Security Consultants, ist es die gleiche, wie sie auch der, in Anführungszeichen, der Hacker da draußen macht oder habt ihr da eine andere?
Na das Ziel ist eigentlich ein anderes, weil das Ziel, wenn man, ich sag mal, wenn man das vom Hacker als illegalem Angreifer aussieht, will man eigentlich nur genau eins. Man will irgendwo ein Loch finden, mit dem man möglichst viele Privilegien möglichst schnell bekommt. Unser Ziel ist eigentlich ein anderes, weil der Auftraggeber ist ja schon daran interessiert zu wissen, okay, wie sieht es denn gesamt aus? Was ist denn, wie schlimm ist es denn? Wie viel Angriffsfläche biete ich und wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass in den Punkten irgendwo Schwachstellen auftreten? Das heißt, wir sind schon mehr auf eine Gesamtabdeckung fokussiert, als auf einen möglichst schnellen Erfolg.
Wenn Fritz in Fürstenwalde, dann 101, 5.
Fritz Info.
Heute Nacht ist es locker bewölkt und trocken. Die Temperaturen kühlen sich ab auf 15 bis 9 Grad. Morgen ist es dann in der Uckermarke anfangs teils wolkig, später überall sonnig. Es soll nicht regnen bei 26 bis 29 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kargoff.
Nach dem Wahldebakel in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat der Landesvorstand der SPD angekündigt, geschlossen zurückzutreten. Das gab der bisherige Landesvorsitzende Schartau in Düsseldorf bekannt. Schartau trat heute zurück. Der Vorstand wird am 9.
Juli folgen.
Neuer Parteichef soll der bisherige Finanzminister Diekmann werden. In Hannover hat der 30. Deutsche Evangelische Kirchentag begonnen. Zum Eröffnungsgottesdienst kamen mehrere 10.000 Menschen, darunter auch Bundeskanzler Schröder und Bundespräsident Köhler. Die Veranstalter warten auf dem fünftägigen Kirchentag mehr als 100.000 Teilnehmer. Nach einem Brand in der Berliner Galeria Kaufhof am Alexanderplatz mussten zwei Personen mit Rauchvergiftungen ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert werden. Nach Angaben der Feuerwehr war bei Bauarbeiten Isoliermaterial in Brand geraten. Zehn Löschfahrzeuge und zusätzliche Sonderfahrzeuge mit insgesamt rund 70 Feuerwehrleuten waren im Einsatz. Zum Sport. In Istanbul findet zur Stunde das Finale der Fußball Champions League statt. Kurz vor dem Ende steht es im Spiel Mailand gegen Liverpool unentschieden 3 zu 3. Der Verkehr auf Ritz hat keine aktuellen Meldungen. Wir wünschen weiter eine gute Fahrt durch die Nacht.
Vielen Dank Matthias. Zwei Minuten nach halb elf.
Ihr hört sie, ihr mögt sie.
Dann wählt sie.
Ihr bestimmt sie und wählt eure Lieblingssongs in die 20 plus 1. Eure Fritz Charts. Letzten Sonntag auf der 3.
Hi.
Hier Chaosradio 102 auf Fritz im Blumen, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Traumberuf Hacker? Fragezeichen ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Es gibt professionelle Hacker und zwei davon sind nämlich auch im Studio. THS und FX sind da und wer was zu sagen hat, hab ich eben gesagt und hier anruft unter 0331 77 97 110. Wird auch gehört und angerufen hat Kevin aus Berlin. Hallo Kevin.
Hallo.
Was können wir für dich tun?
Ja ich hab mal ne Frage, also wie kann man kann man das irgendwie schützen oder so?
Wo vor?
Vor so ne Hex, weil es war nämlich mal so gewesen, ich wollte mal ins Internet gehen, bei mir zu Hause und dann tippe ich alles ein so, auf einmal stand da so dieser, also dieser Benutzer ist schon im Internet irgendwie so.
Ja, das ist aber schon so ein typisches Problemchen eigentlich was, naja, das ist halt so eine so eine Hotline Frage.
Das ist eine Hotline Frage und heute geht es dann tatsächlich nicht darum die Hotline für Leute, die unbedingt Windows benutzen wollen, hier zu machen im Radio, sondern wirklich darum das Berufsbild des Security Consultants, also des Hackers, des Professionellen abzubilden. Also da würde ich sagen, kauft ihr ein Handbuch, in dem es um Sicherheit für deinen Desktop PC geht.
Wir wollen es nicht.
Alles klar?
Nix für ungut, Kevin.
Was denn?
Na ja, vielleicht hätte ich da noch eine andere Frage oder so.
Ja bitte.
Und zwar nämlich, wie sieht denn das aus, wie lange, also auch mal für so eine spezielle Ausbildung, also so eine Qualifikation irgendwie.
Was habt ihr für eine Qualifikation?
Das wäre eigentlich die Frage. Ich glaube, warte mal eben. Manuel? Ich vermute, die selbe Frage wolltest du auch stellen, oder? Wie bildet man sich dahingehend aus?
Ich glaube, da kommen wir im Laufe des Abends auf jeden Fall noch zu. Wir haben ja gerade erst angefangen und bisher noch gar nichts weiter dazu gesagt.
Also wie man es wird, ist glaube ich auch eher euer Problem. Also was ihr heute Abend hier hören könnt, ist, was ihr können müsst, um es zu sein.
Es gibt keinen Studiengang oder keine Berufsausbildung.
Es ist ungefähr dasselbe wie bei jedem interessanten Beruf. Man muss eigentlich schon mal das richtige Mitbringung eingestellt werden.
Und was das sein könnte, das erfahrt ihr im Laufe der Sendung. Okay, Jungs.
Ja, hallo.
Ich hab noch eine andere Frage. Wie man also ich versuche auch ab und zu sowas eben natürlich nicht auf solcher Basis, dass ich das beruflich machen würde. Ich würde gerne wissen, ob man irgendwie PHP Skripte kopieren kann.
Wie kopieren?
Also kopieren, dass ich die nicht ausführe.
Du meinst, wir jetzt hier runterladen und der Herbstball dann, das geht, wenn es ja wirklich eingestellt ist nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich auch so ein bisschen eher so eine Hotline Frage für heute.
Ja, ich wollte auch noch sagen, ich wollte zwei Seiten durchgeben, wo man einfach so Hacken ausprobieren kann.
Wo man Hacken ausprobieren kann?
So kleine Hacker Schule ist in der alten CT drin.
Kleine Hacker Schule?
Ja, das ist die kleine Hacker Schule. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es die Seiten noch gibt. Also ohne WWW.
Du weißt nicht, ob es sie gibt, aber du willst sie durchgeben.
Das ist die kleine Hacker Schule, wir finden das schon.
Ne, ne, ne, das heißt sie nicht so direkt. Das steht hier nur als Überschrift.
Und da kann man sich dann selbst testen, ob man Hacker ist oder nicht.
Da konnte man so durchgehen. Ich glaube, ich bin da irgendwo stecken geblieben beim JavaScript. Ich bin stecken geblieben beim JavaScript dekompilieren.
Und ja, also wenn man so was auf einem Level testen möchte, sich selbst testen möchte, auf dem Level, auf dem wir arbeiten, gibt es von der Envance auch in relativ, im relativer Bälle, also ich würde mal sagen so einen Monat oder so was, ein sogenanntes Capture the Flag Game. Das heißt, da kann man sich mal ausprobieren und da ist das Ziel nicht so weit zu kommen, wie man kann, sondern primär das Ziel ist, das anständig zu dokumentieren, was man macht und das kann man dann einsenden.
Das ist auch wahrscheinlich das Wichtigste, dass eben auch die Sicherheitslöcher anständig dokumentiert werden.
Also ich glaube, da kommen wir jetzt auch gerade genau zu dieser Vorgehensweise.
Ja, warte mal, Janko hat eine Frage zum Film, die will ich unbedingt.
Ich wollte doch fragen, wie realistisch denn diese Welt in diesem Film überhaupt ist, wie die dargestellt wird.
Das können wir dir sagen.
Hör mal, willst du zur Elite gehören?
Dann musst du mit Verstand hacken und nicht unkontrollieren. Wenn du wirklich einen echten Hack machen willst, dann solltest du den Gibson von Enjoy. Ihr wisst schon, das sind die Computer, die sie in der Medizin ansetzen und bei der Suche nach Öl und so.
Das kannst du vergessen, die Sicherheitsverkehrungen sind zu eng.
So was knackst du nicht. Schon möglich, aber wenn ich in ein Heavy-Metal-System rein will, dann versuch ich durch die Hintertür, wo die Sicherheitsstufen leichter zu umgehen sind.
Könnte jemand Janko jetzt noch eine ernsthafte Antwort geben?
Ich meine, das war ja auch so, dass zum Anfang des Films zum Beispiel auch so eine TV-Stattsilbernung wurde. Ist das realistisch, dass Hacker jetzt machen oder ist es einfach nur so für den Film da einfach so gereingemacht worden?
Ja, vielleicht könnt ihr was aus der Praxis sagen, wie er realistisch...
Also man sieht schon regelmäßig Pferdekotzen.
Dass einfach einmal was im Fernsehen läuft, was die Fernsehanstalt nicht will, das läuft.
Also realistisch würde ich sagen, es geht, aber es ist sehr viel aufwendiger als man sich das so vorstellt.
Und vor allem nicht so bunt.
Ne. Und das nennt man dann dramaturgische Zuspitzung.
Genau, aber Hacken ist natürlich schon, also es findet auch statt und es passiert auch, und Systeme haben einfach Sicherheitslücken. Und insofern ist es halt nicht ganz abwegig, was da passiert.
Und ansonsten ist der Film für euch eher so eine Lachnummer, eher auch so schön sowas, was Leute dazu animieren könnte, zu Hackern zu werden oder sich...
Also das beantworte ich mal. Also ich verfüge wirklich von allen hier im Studio über den wenigsten und geringsten Sachverstand. Und für mich ist dieser Film eine Lachnummer.
Ja, also vor allem immer dieses Elite-Tour, das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig. Also zu uns, zum CTC kommen ja auch nochmal Leute, die sagen, wir wollen jetzt zur Elite gehören und was müssen wir da tun? Dann können wir dann halt auch immer nur schmunzeln. Also ich glaub, mir persönlich gefällt, man kann's ehrlich sagen, mir gefällt War Games zum Beispiel deutlich besser. Weil er so realistischer, trockener ist und gibt Zeit.
Ich mach jetzt wirklich schon jahrelang Sendungen mit den Jungs von Chaos Computer Club und hab sehr, sehr viele von denen schon kennengelernt. Und ich habe noch nie jemanden kennengelernt, der so alt man drauf ist, wie die Jungs und Mädels bei Hackers.
Wobei die Motivation gar nicht so weit ab vom Schuss ist.
Okay.
Also die Motivationspunkte in dem Film, warum die Leute irgendwelche Dinge angreifen, sind durchaus realistisch.
Ja gut, aber die ist ja auch naheliegend, die Motivation, oder?
Na ja, man darf nicht vergessen, dass sie tatsächlich da die Seattle Szene komplett interviewt haben. Also die Leute, die in dem Film vorkommen, bis auf zwei Personen, sind auch alle real.
Dann bin ich froh, dass ich es euch noch nicht getroffen hab.
Jo, wie sieht es aus, wenn ihr so bei der Vorgehensweise, wenn jetzt so ein System ist, wir hatten ja schon gesagt, also ihr guckt euch das an, dann werden da so Support Scans gemacht, das heißt also wird vom Netz ausgeschaut, ob da irgendwelche Dienste offen sind, wo ich also von außen möglicherweise eindringen kann oder wo bekannt ist, dass die Dienste Sicherheitslücken haben. Wir haben jetzt auch gerade schon gehört, Dokumentation ist wichtig. Ist es denn eher eine technische oder eher bürokratische Sache zu einer Arbeit?
Sowohl als auch, also das ist immer so der krönende Abschluss von irgendwelchen Tests. Also man muss das Ganze halt ziemlich bürokratisch für irgendwelche Entscheider so formulieren, dass sie das unter Umständen auch verstehen. Und das ist natürlich auch sehr techniklastig, weil die Schwachstellen, die man gefunden hat, die müssen da halt natürlich ausführlich dokumentiert werden.
Wie ist es vom Anta her prozentual? 10% hacken, 90% Dokumentation schreiben?
Das ist total unterschiedlich. Also mal so, mal so. Also manchmal brauche ich auch irgendwie vier Tage für einen Bericht, der dann auch bis 80 Seiten oder 100 Seiten lang wird für ein Projekt, was drei Tage gedauert hat oder so.
Wie lange ist denn so ein Projekt in der Regel? Oder was sind da so typische Projektaufzeiten? Wie lange dauert es, so ein System anzuschauen?
Das ist auch wieder sehr abhängig vom Auftrag, den man bekommt.
Okay, welches System hast du dir schon mal angeschaut? Wie lange hat es gedauert? Darfst du das sagen?
Also du musst ja keinen Namen nennen.
Nein, es ist wie gesagt total unterschiedlich. Also das hängt halt davon ab, was die Kunden genau haben wollen, wie ausführlich das sein soll, wenn ein Kunde kommt und sagt, wir haben hier eine Web-Applikation und die soll bitte getestet werden, dann ist es halt eine Web-Applikation, kann schnell gehen, kann ein paar Tage dauern, aber in der Regel sind das dann halt Projekte, die auf wenige Tage angesetzt werden oder halt die Kunden kommen mit kompletten Netzwerk-Ranges, also ganz vielen IP-Adressen und geben einem halt keine Informationen. Da muss man sich die Informationen zusammensammeln und halt gucken, was es da gibt. Also halt bei diesen klassischen Penetrationstests von externen übers Netzwerk.
Wie sinnvoll ist denn so eine Untersuchung?
Also wie oder Felix, du wolltest nach? Naja, das hängt auch, also diese Laufzeiten und wie das eigentlich abläuft, wie viel, das hängt auch sehr stark von der Art und Weise, wie das jeweilige Unternehmen, was man beauftragt, arbeitet ab. Also das ist tatsächlich so, dass es da unterschiedliche Ansätze gibt, die einen sagen halt, hey, wir machen jetzt so lange, bis wir bei euch alles gefunden haben, was wir für wichtig halten. Man kann natürlich auch dahergehen, dass wir es gewöhnlich machen, weil es ist einfacher vorher sehr genau festzulegen, worum kümmern wir uns und vorher schon möglichst so viel rauszufinden, dass man sehr genau sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt so und so kompliziert. Und das gucken wir uns an. Und wenn wir uns das jetzt, sagen wir, zwei Wochen anschauen, dann bekommt ihr folgende Aussagen ziemlich sicher. Folgende Aussagen hängen davon ab, wie viel Ärger wir haben und folgende Aussagen bekommt ihr gar nicht. Und die müssen sie dann auch bekommen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch dann wichtig, um das Angebot erst mal zu stellen, um dem Kunden erst mal einen Preis zu sagen.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn du dein Auto in die Werkstatt bringst. Du möchtest halt auch nicht von dem Menschen hören, naja, ich arbeite jetzt hier daran und dann kriegst du es irgendwie ganz wieder und dann gibt er dir irgendeine Rechnung. Sondern du möchtest eigentlich schon wissen, was macht er, was macht er nicht, wie viel kostet, komme ich danach durch den TÜV oder nicht?
Ja, dann praktisch bevor ihr anfängt, macht ihr dann quasi so eine Art Checkliste oder so eine Art Liste. Was guckt ihr euch alles an?
Das nennt sich dann Scoping. Dann sagt man da ganz klar, okay, das gehört zu dem, was wir uns anschauen und das gehört nicht dazu. Man muss natürlich auch rausfinden, was ist die Motivation dahinter, warum machen die Leute das? Man muss eventuell ihren Vorstellungen von dem Scope noch ein bisschen die richtige Richtung geben.
Und wenn ihr denn fertig seid, dann gibt es irgendwie diesen Bericht und können die sich dann so raufkleben und so ein Stempel irgendwie Hacker Certified oder Hacker Zertifiziert, antlich geprüft, sicher oder wie sieht das denn aus? Was bekommen die Leute denn in die Hand?
Gehen die Kunden eine Momentaufnahme?
In erster Linie bekommen sie halt den Bericht. Das ist das einzige, was sie tatsächlich in den Händen halten können. Also das Produkt, was sie quasi eingekauft haben. Es ist natürlich dann irgendwie die Frage, ob das irgendwie im Vertrag geregelt wurde, ob es dann irgendwelche Zertifikate gibt oder so. Das ist in der Regel nicht so. Es gibt Unternehmen, die stellen Zertifikate aus für irgendwelche Web Shops oder sonst was Software, ist aber eigentlich nicht die Regel. Eigentlich bleibt es bei einem Bericht und ist halt auch die Motivation der Kunden, ob sie irgendwie eine Software testen lassen wollen, um anschließend damit zu werben, dass sie getestet wurde oder ob sie eine Applikation testen lassen, um sie tatsächlich sicher zu bekommen.
Ja, Musik zu der wir auf jeden Fall was sagen sollten, nicht wahr, Ters? Die hast du selbst gemacht?
Na natürlich.
Du spielst als was?
Saxophon, aber das hat man eben nicht gehört. Ich war gerade so, aber das waren auf jeden Fall Cut My Skin aus Berlin-Kreuzberg.
Cut My Skin mit Hands of Blood. Chaos Radio 102 ist es, was ihr hört. Traumberuf Hacker? Fragezeichen haben wir es genannt. Frank, was?
Ein Hackerstück hätte ich jetzt gerne.
Ich bin in dem Computer, versteht ihr? Ich seh mich ein bisschen um, ihr wisst schon.
Hier gibt es ein paar Befehle ein, weiß natürlich nicht, was sie bringen oder bewirken.
Es geschieht alles ganz zufällig.
Alles ganz zufällig.
Ich bin nicht süchtig.
Das ist genau das, was man nicht will.
Dass alles ganz zufällig passiert.
Wir haben an euch, an euch Hörer haben wir eine Frage. Wir wollen nämlich gerne wissen, habt ihr irgendwelche Ideen, was sich die beiden mal ansehen? Was kommt euch besonders suspekt vor an Systemen da draußen? Wo hättet ihr die beiden gern mal reingeschaut?
Also unsere beiden Security Experten. 0331 70 97 110 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Vielleicht seid ihr über die eine oder andere Web-Applikation, wie ich eben gestolpert habe, und seid der Meinung, da muss mal ein Blick drauf geworfen werden. Da liegt irgendetwas im Argen.
Jo, also Web-Applikationen sind halt zum Beispiel, das kann eine Homebanking-Geschichte sein, es kann ein Forum sein, es kann alles mögliche, irgendwelche Shopping-Geschichten sein.
Vielleicht habt ihr das Gefühl, dass euer Handy unsicher ist.
Ja, Handys, genau. Es war keine Web-Applikation, aber auch ein System. Ja, natürlich. Also Handys sind mittlerweile so komplex wie halt jeder andere Computer auch. Vielleicht keine Festplatte drin, aber ansonsten ist da ungefähr das Gleiche drin auch. Und dementsprechend ist die Software auch mittlerweile so komplex, dass es sich auf jeden Fall auch lohnt zu analysieren, weil je komplexer die Software ist, desto mehr Schwachstellen.
Oder habt ihr schon mal daran gedacht, was eigentlich passiert, wenn euer Navigationssystem rausfindet, dass da irgendwo Stau ist?
Ja, das habe ich jetzt nicht so ganz verstanden. Aber ist das denn auch eine Arbeit, die ein Security Consultant macht, tatsächlich zu überprüfen oder fast sicherzustellen, dass mein Handy nicht dauernd abstürzt, weil es zu komplex ist? Ist das auch euer Job oder ist das schon?
Naja, sicherstellen kann man sowieso nicht.
Ja, wenn jemand anders machen kann, dass dein Handy immer abstürzt, ist das unser Job.
Aber nicht, also gut, wen verklage ich, weil es trotzdem immer abstürzt, obwohl niemand anders was macht? Ich kann auch nicht mehr sagen, was denn die Sendung heißt.
Chaos Radio 100 und 2.
Hacker dringen in private und behördliche Computersysteme ein und verursachen einen Chaos. Sie infizieren sie mit Viren und stehlen Material, das sie dann für ihre eigenen Zwecke verwenden. Diese Leute sind Terroristen.
Und zwei von den Terroristen haben wir hier nämlich, Efex und Efex, das sind beides Terroristen. Security Consultants, also berufsmäßige Hacker, das was Hacker eigentlich gar nicht waren, oder? Ist das doch... Ihr habt ihr angefangen oder haben Hacker überhaupt angefangen, um damit mal irgendwann Geld zu verdienen, also daraus einen Beruf zu machen?
Ich denke keiner hat deswegen damit angefangen.
Weswegen hast du angefangen?
Ich wollte eigentlich wissen, was diese Hacker denn da so tun.
Also ähnlich wie unsere Anrufer eben mit 13, 15 Jahren.
Große, schwarze Magie und mal rausfinden, was hinter der schwarzen Magie liegt.
Und was hast du gefunden?
Viel Spaß.
Eigentlich ähnlich. Also ich meine halt einfach wissen, was da passiert, verstehen, was da passiert und eben einen guten Überblick darüber haben, was mein Computer gerade für mich tut und so weiter.
Aber wie viel hat denn der Job, den ihr jetzt macht als Security Consultant, das ist bei mich immer so, das sind Leute, die irgendwie mit Anzug und Schlipschen zu Firmen gehen, mit einem Kofferchen auf den Tisch und guten Tag. Was können wir für Sie tun? Wir beraten Sie gern. Das schreiben Sie bitte hier und der checkt da. Wie hat es was mit Hacker-Realität zu tun? Oder wie ist da so diese, ist da möglicherweise ein Diskrepanz? Oder was hat Security Consultant eigentlich noch mit Hacker zu tun?
Ich würde sagen, der Hacker ist innen und das, was du beschrieben hast, ist außen.
Geht ihr tatsächlich auch mit... Alles über den Koffer? In dem Koffer ist die Million, die...
Na, der Koffer ist ein Rucksack, weil das ganze Equipment, was du brauchst, ist dermaßen schwer. Also ich hatte mal einen Koffer und wenn man über den Flughafen rennt, reißt man sich eigentlich den rechten Arm aus.
Also geht er schon hin einfach und klappt den Laptop auf und legt den Netzwerkkabel rein und legt los?
Na, das ist schon ein bisschen geplanter.
Also ich meine, wenn das Konzept schon steht, oder ist das so, macht ihr denn tatsächlich auch das Konzept? Oder gibt es jetzt so Leute, die jetzt mehr so, sag ich mal, businessmäßig draußen, die dann so diese ganzen Papierkram machen und ihr seid dann die coolen Jungs, die dann irgendwie mit dem Netzwerkkabel schnell rankommen, irgendwie klacklacklack und dann ist das Ergebnis da? Oder macht ihr das schon, betreut ihr so ein Projekt von Anfang bis Ende?
Na schon von Anfang bis Ende. Stell dir das eigentlich eher vor, als wenn du mit irgendetwas zu einer Stelle, sagen wir zu irgendeinem TÜV, gehst und sagst, hier überprüft das. Also das ist schon ein ziemlich geplanter Vorgang.
Das heißt also da kommen die Leute quasi mit dem Auto zu euch reingefahren und ihr krabbelt dann drunter und guckt mal mit der Taschenlampe, kommt klopft mal gegen und so.
So in der Art nur, dass wir zu den Leuten fahren müssen, die das Auto haben.
Ist klar. Und ihr kriegt dann, also wir haben, es gibt ja diesen Bericht, da haben wir schon gesprochen und die können möglicherweise denn auch, für wen ist es eigentlich wichtig, dass sowas denn überprüft wird? Also wer verlangt das irgendjemand, dass so eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung gemacht wird? Oder was ist da die Motivation für die Firmen das zu machen? Dann oder die, werden die dazu gezwungen? Oder ist es eine Marketinggeschichte oder?
Ja, das hatte ich ja vorhin schon so erwähnt, dass es wohl auch sein kann, dass es eben eine Marketinggeschichte ist, wenn es eben ein Zertifikat für irgendwas gibt oder wenn eben ein Zertifikat eingekauft wird, dann ist natürlich klar, dass diese Unternehmen damit ausschließlich werben will. Das gibt natürlich auch Unternehmen, die in erster Linie Wert auf ihre Sicherheit legen oder halt gerade einen Einbruch hatten und dann eben aufgewacht sind und festgestellt haben, dass man eben so einen Security Check wie auch immer auf jeden Fall mal durchführen sollte. Oder halt eben Unternehmen, die eine Software produzieren, die halt auch irgendwie einen gewissen Sicherheitsaspekt da berücksichtigen und eben diese Software mal von unabhängigen Leuten untersuchen lassen.
Das wird auch zunehmend wichtiger, weil die Leute gemerkt haben, also die Hersteller haben gemerkt, dass es durchaus ein Kostenfaktor ist, wenn man alle Nase lang auf irgendwelche Heisetägern landet, weil irgendwas in der Software kaputt ist. Dann hat man eine ganze Menge Kosten, vor allem hat man Riesenmarketingkosten, diesen Imageschaden wieder wegzumachen. Und man muss halt auch die Sachen dann irgendwie fixen. Und sie haben schon langsam begriffen, dass der Hersteller eigentlich derjenige ist, der sich das angucken sollte und möglichst nochmal jemand dritten drüber gucken lassen sollte, bevor er es auf den Markt wirft.
Warum wird es nicht gleich ordentlich gemacht? Ich meine, wenn ich mir ein Auto kaufe, frisch ab Werk, dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass ich die nächsten drei Jahre nur Öl nachkippen muss?
Das ist nicht korrekt. Wenn du dir einen Ford Jeep gekauft hast, dann musstest du jetzt ein paar Mal wieder in die Werkstatt fahren, weil er potenziell explodieren könnte.
Ein Glück hab ich mir keinen Ford Jeep gekauft. Gut, aber warum wird das nicht sofort, während die Software designed wird oder während die Software geschrieben wird, mit eingebaut? Warum geht man hinterher zu euch?
Zeit ist Geld. Also ich meine, gute Programmierer kosten auch Geld. Also viele Unternehmen heuern ja auch immer viele Studenten an, Praktikanten, um halt Geld zu sparen und um schnell ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen zu können, weil eben die Konkurrenz auch da ist und der Druck in der Hinsicht auch ziemlich groß ist. Da wird natürlich schnell mal irgendwas released, was eigentlich noch nicht so richtig fertig ist. Da ist es wichtiger, wenn die ganzen Features implementiert sind eben für die Schlips-Etage und die singen das dann ab und sagen, prima, können wir verkaufen, super.
Das heißt, es ist billiger, wenn ich hinterher mit einem fertigen Produkt zu euch gehe und das überprüfen lasse, als dass ich noch einen Programmierer oder zwei einstelle, die das Ding gebaut haben.
Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Also ja, so als würde bei Toyota auf einmal keine ordentlichen Autos mehr bauen, sondern nur noch Rückrufe machen.
Wir suchen halt Fehler. Wenn wir keine Fehler gefunden haben, ist es keine Aussage darüber, ob diese Software fehlerfrei ist. Das ist viel wichtiger, dass die Programmierer da gewissenhaft rangehen und eben halt auch eine gewisse Erfahrung mitbringen und das eben von vornherein vernünftig programmieren.
Nachzuweisen, dass irgendwas nicht ist, ist schwer.
Du kannst es auch eigentlich nie perfekt machen. Die Sachen sind dermaßen komplex. Also bei einer anständigen Software reden wir von ein paar Millionen Codeszahlen. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit nachzuweisen, dass diese 100% funktionieren. Wenn das irgendwann jemand rausfindet, dann ist er sowieso der Oberheld.
Chaosradio 102 auf Fritz hacken als Beruf heute Abend das Thema und THX und FX sind hier im Studio zu Gast und das sind professionelle Hacker, nämlich Security Consultants.
Und wir wollen eigentlich auch nochmal ein bisschen darstellen, dass das eigentlich eher ein, naja, vielleicht nicht trockener Beruf, aber eher schon, also wirklich richtig seriös ist. Also wir haben jetzt immer so ein paar Sound-Schnipsel gehört aus dem Film Hackers und da wird ja schon ein sehr skurriles Bild herweise von Hackern gezeichnet. Und wir wollen eigentlich heute mal zeigen, dass wenn man so was berufsmäßig macht, wie der Arbeitsalltag da wirklich ist und ob das dann wirklich so toll ist.
Du bumst hoffentlich besser als du tippst, weil das ist auch etwas schwer zu verstehen. So viel Spaß macht eurer Beruf.
Nochmal zurück zu den Motivationen der Firmen, so was machen zu lassen. Gibt es denn da auch auch wirklich knallharte finanzielle Gründe außer jetzt der der möglichen Rufschädigung, wenn jetzt ein Hacker in ein System eingedrungen ist? Es gibt irgendwie eine Pressemeldung da und da Sicherheitslücke. Haben wir mittlerweile regelmäßig einmal pro Woche oder alle zwei Wochen mal, dass da was Großes passiert ist. Was können noch so viele mögliche Gründe sein, die Firmen dazu bewegen, so eine Sicherheitsanalyse zu machen? Die ist ja auch nicht ganz billig.
Also es gibt halt eigentlich die Hauptgründe sind gesetzliche Regelungen. Also es gibt halt einfach Unternehmen, die Dinge tun, die gesetzlichen Regelungen unterliegen. Also wenn man überhaupt gar keinen Schutz hat und man hat Kundendaten und die gehen verloren, dann ist es eigentlich schon ein Verschluss gegen Datenschutzgesetz mit grober Fahrlässigkeit, wenn man zum Beispiel gar nicht nach einem Passwort fragt. Dann gibt es total Bereiche wie Medizintechnik, die müssen halt einfach zertifiziert werden, sonst dürfen die überhaupt nicht eingesetzt werden. Das ist die gesetzliche Seite, die ist relativ wichtig. Und dann ist es natürlich auch so, wenn in deinem Netzwerk sich irgendwie ein paar Punks rumtreiben und ganz viel Spaß haben, dann funktioniert eventuell was nicht, weil die machen halt auch mal was kaputt. Die kümmern sich halt nicht wirklich darum, ob es läuft. Und dann ist der Support teurer, dann läuft das Netz nicht. Im schlechtesten Fall hat man Datenverlust. Das kostet richtig Geld.
Wir hatten hier während die Musik lief von dem Begriff Hackerversicherung. Gibt es so was wirklich?
Gibt es wirklich. Ich weiß nicht mehr von welcher Gesellschaft, aber ich weiß, dass man definitiv einen Penetrationstest hat machen lassen müssen vorher und diesen Bericht auch einreichen. Und da gibt es auch nur ein paar Unternehmen, die das dürfen. Und dann reicht man denen ein und dann kriegen die eine Anti Hackerversicherung.
Was gegen was versichert die denn genau?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wenn Hacker vorbeikommt und krank ist und die Mitarbeiter ansteckt und so.
Finanziell kann das schon ganz groß reinhauen, weil so ein größeres Unternehmen, wenn da irgendwelche Server aufgemacht wurden, entweder es tritt ein Datenverlust auf oder Daten werden manipuliert oder es gibt Schadensersatzklagen von irgendwelchen Kunden, deren Kreditkarten, Informationen dort gestohlen wurden oder oder oder. Also das kann alles mögliche sein.
Also es gibt auch häufig diese Anwendung, wenn du irgendwas mit E-Business machst, also wenn deine Dienstleistung online verkaufst, wenn du deine Software online verkaufst, ähnliches. Wenn da die Maschine aufgemacht wird und jemand kriegt die Vollversion for free oder baut es vielleicht sogar so um, dass jeder die Vollversion runterzieht statt die Demo-Version, wie es eigentlich gedacht ist, dann ist der theoretische finanzielle Verlust doch relativ hoch und das kann man in so einer Versicherung dann auch glaubhaft machen.
Chaosradio 102 hacken als Beruf mit zwei Security Consultants zu Gast im Studio. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz Hotline, nicht der Windows Hotline. Panda aus Berlin hat angerufen. Und wie hast du's?
Also wozu ich eigentlich nochmal was sagen wollte, das könnt ihr euch ja wahrscheinlich auch schon denken, dass ich dieses Thema noch ansprechen würde, dass ihr vielleicht noch ein paar Worte dazu verliert, wie man denn zumindest im Groben unterscheiden kann bzw. woran man sich orientieren sollte, wenn es denn um die Auswahl des Unternehmens geht, dass eine derartige Untersuchung durchführen soll, weil es gibt ja nun mal auch ein ziemliches Rudelidioten, die sich auf den Markt drum treiben.
Zum Beispiel?
Ja, da hatten wir schon drüber diskutiert, wann wir das Thema aufgreifen.
Wie wär's denn mit...
Ja, ich bin doch mal hilfreich.
Äh Panda, wir haben ja einen, also die Männer im Radio, die dürfen ja nie dissen, ne? Also wen meinst du nur mit Idioten? Weil Anrufer dürfen das.
Achso, ähm, na ich nenn doch keine Namen.
Na gut.
Mist, fast den Foto hergeklappt.
Sag das S-Wort.
den ich quasi als Dalai Lama bezeichnen würde.
Aber du hast doch bestimmt eine Motivation, warum du jetzt hier anrufst und versuchst, auf dieses Thema zu kommen, also...
Du suchst konkret was, eine Firma, die du beauftragen kannst?
Nein, ich sage mal so, ich kenne mich mit der Branche auch ein kleines bisschen aus.
Na gut, er kennt sich mit der Branche ein kleines bisschen aus.
Dann nennen wir mal keinen Namen. Nee, dann nennen wir mal keinen Namen. Aber was glaubt ihr denn, zeichnet eine Firma aus oder was zeichnet sie genau nicht aus als eine Firma? Was ist da so für jemand, der jetzt losgeht, so eine Firma vielleicht sucht, möglicherweise auch für eine kleine Firma, die irgendwas anbieten und dann mal so eine kleine Sicherheitsüberprüfung machen will?
Im Prinzip, ich bin ein beliebiges KMU, also ein kleines mittelständisches Unternehmen und hab dann irgendwie mir so einen Shop machen lassen von wem.
Ja, oder was auch immer. Genau.
Also die Geschichte ist halt, ich denke, am einfachsten findet man es raus. Es gibt erst mal nicht so viele Anbieter, die das tatsächlich serious und hauptberuflich machen. Das findet man schon raus, wenn man die Firmenwebseiten sich anschaut. Wenn da steht, wir machen Sicherheitsüberprüfungen aller Art und wir testen alles und wir machen auch alles sicher, dann kann man eigentlich schon getrost den Browser wieder zumachen. Wenn man dann sich ein paar ausgesucht hat, die so aussehen, als könnte man mit denen was anfangen, kann man natürlich mehr Nachforschung anstellen, aber das ist meistens für Kunden viel zu aufwendig. Was man einfach machen sollte, ist die Anrufen. Da gibt es dann einen Vertrieb, wenn es den schon mal nicht gibt, dann kann man das auch gleich wieder lassen. Und dann merkt man schon am Vorgehen, ob es Sinn macht oder nicht. Also wenn die sich ein paar mal vorher mit dir unterhalten und sich hinsetzen und erst mal rausfinden, okay, warum willst du das eigentlich machen? Worauf kommt es dir an, worauf kommt es dir nicht an? So ein bisschen Beratung. Das ist fast wie die Typberatung vor dem Friseurtermin, ob sie jetzt gleich anfangen, dir den Schädelkahl zu rasieren oder ob sie halt vorher mal rausfinden wollen, wie du eigentlich nachher aussehen willst. Das gibt dir einfach ein Gefühl dafür.
Ist Security Consultant eigentlich eine geschützte Bezeichnung? Berufsbezeichnung? Kann also jeder werden einfach. Holger kann jetzt losgehen und sagt, ich bin jetzt Security Consultant.
Leider ja.
Zumindestens bei Computersystemen ist es so. Also ich glaube bei Autos, da muss man schon, da gibt es ja staatliche, vererdigte Sachverständige.
Hey kann auch jeder sagen, er ist Programmierer und Softwarehersteller.
Und das ist, das machen viele.
Journalist und Security Consultant.
Das ist ja aber auch mitunter wirklich das ärgerliche. Das ist eigentlich für eine ganze Menge technischer Errungenschaften tatsächlich solche Erfordernisse gibt. Das heißt, dass die Sachen wirklich richtig getestet werden müssen, bevor sie denn auf den Markt bzw. auf die Öffentlichkeit losgelassen werden. Und im Computerbereich gibt es das einfach mal nicht. Mit wenigen Ausnahmen, FX hatte ja schon von den Systemen im Medizinbereich gesprochen, aber das ist eigentlich auch so ziemlich das Einzige, was mir anfällt.
Warum gibt es einen staatlich vereiligten Sachverständigen für Automobile oder Kraftfahrzeuge? Warum gibt es das nicht für IT-Sicherheit? Oder gibt es das und keiner will es werden?
Weil es wahrscheinlich auch Schwachsinn wäre.
Ja, aber dass so wenigstens sowas, also wenigstens in irgendeiner Form ein Qualifikationsstandard, also eine ISO 9000 für Security-Konserts.
Ja, aber wer beurteilt denn, ob die Firma, die dieses Zertifikat ausstellt, auch wirklich über das notwendige Wissen verfügt, sowas zu tun hat? Es gab irgendwie mal ein Unternehmen, soweit ich mich daran erinnern kann, das hat irgendwie Windows XP als sicheres Betriebssystem zertifiziert. Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Also es gibt schon sowas. Es gibt von unserem Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Und hier gibt es diese IT-Grundschutz-Zertifizierung, die es einmal für Gesamtsysteme gibt und einmal für Produkte. Das ist, da kann man sich auch ein bisschen drum rummogeln, aber man kann zumindest nicht totale Scheiße gebaut haben und diese Zertifizierung bekommen. Also es gibt es schon.
Mir ging es jetzt nicht um Produkte, sondern mir ging es um euch, also um die Concerts. Also dass es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gibt, eine Gütesiegel für euch einzuführen. Also quasi den Meisterbetrieb.
Das wäre ja schön, aber das Gütesiegel würde dann vom BSI kommen und naja wir bringen denen was bei und nicht ungedreht. Also das ist wieder ein bisschen problematisch.
Ja mein Gott, dann gründet ihr eben eine Genossenschaft, die weiß ich nicht, sich gegenseitig kontrolliert oder so.
Genau, alle die eine Security Consulting Genossenschaft gründen wollen, rufen bitte an.
301 77 90 110. Chaosradio 102 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline und Traumberuf Hacker Fragezeichen. Das Thema des heutigen Abends. Und Volker aus Nordrhein-Westfalen hat angerufen. Wo genau?
Aus Kast.
Bei Neuss, bei Düsseldorf.
Ja genau, aus dem Kastdorf. Und zwar geht meine Frage so ein bisschen in die Richtung Industriespionage. Also wie stellt man denn fest jetzt als Firma, wenn man euch beauftragt, ob ihr nicht von der Konkurrenz seid und da die Konkurrenz einfach mal gesagt hat, ja, geht mal da, wenn ihr mal bei so einer Firma seid, geht mal dahin und guckt mal, ob er da Sicherheitslücken gibt.
Das ist genau das Erfolgsrezept.
Das ist nicht das Erfolgsrezept. Also es gibt da drei magische Buchstaben, die die ultimative Wache sind. Die heißen NDA, Non-Disclosure Agreement. Das heißt, wenn man mit uns redet, selbst wenn man uns nicht beauftragt, hat man vorher eine vertragliche Regelung, dass wir das keinem anderen erzählen.
Ja, also vertragliche Regelungen können ja gebrochen werden. Also das ist ja so nach dem Motto, wer kontrolliert die Kontrolleure?
Also wenn du irgendwie so paranoid bist und denkst, die Firma, die du da gerade aus dem gelben Seiten rausgesucht hast, wird dich dann ausspionieren. Das ist natürlich, ja, ich meine, wer garantiert dir das, wenn du dein Auto zum TÜV schiebst, dass sie dir da nicht eine Autobombe drunter bauen?
Also ja klar, also ich meine, sind da denn schon so Fälle bekannt geworden oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Also der Punkt ist, der Punkt ist, das ist schon ein relativ auch finanziell recht aufwendige Geschichte, Leute zu beauftragen, sich das anzugucken. Und man muss sich schon Mühe geben, dass man seine Kunden pflegt und salopp gesagt, man leistet sich einmal irgendwie so eine Nummer, dass man irgendwas rausgibt an Informationen, was man nicht hätte rausgeben sollen. Und dann ist man aus dem Geschäft. Das war's. Also das ist ja ein Vertrauensjob. Und wenn die Kunden kein Vertrauen haben, dann ist es halt vorbei und man zerstört sich in Sekunden das Geschäft.
Also bei so einer Kundendatenbank oder so kann sowas für eine Firma ja schon mal ziemlich lukrativ sein.
Nicht wirklich.
Es ist nicht kurzfristig lukrativ, aber nicht mal.
Also wie viele Millionen musst du haben, um dein Leben lang nicht mehr arbeiten zu müssen?
Ja, stimmt auch wieder.
Also das ist das lohnt nicht. Wirklich billig.
Ganz kurz noch mal zu den finanziell aufwendig.
Genau, finanziell aufwendig.
Was ist denn finanziell? Wie hoch ist denn finanziell aufwendig? Sag einfach mal ein paar Zahlen.
Angenommen, also ich bin jetzt Nokia und ich habe jetzt ein Handy 6328 gebastelt und das möchte ich gerne überprüfen lassen.
Nee, dafür nicht. Aber was man so sagen kann, Industriedurchschnitt weltweit ist, dass ein Mannntag, also eine qualifizierte Person, einen Tag, also acht Stunden, ungefähr sich im Bereich von 1000 Euro bewegt.
Wie viele Mannntage? Also gibt es irgendwie ein griffiges Beispiel, eine Software oder was auch immer, was jeder kennt? Wie viele Mannntage da ungefähr notwendig sind zum überprüfen?
Was jeder kennt geht ja nicht, weil ich kann ja nicht sagen, welche Software es ist. Aber das hängt wirklich davon ab, was man tut. Aber es spielt sich gewöhnlich in den größten Ordnung von einer Woche bis sechs Wochen in beliebiger Skalierung von Leute, meistens zwei bis vier.
Das heißt also eine Woche, zwei Leute, zehn Mannntage, 10.000 Euro?
Wäre eine Hausnummer.
Das geht aber denn an die Firma, die euch denn beauftragt. Also wer arbeitet als Freelancer, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe?
Ich nicht.
Du nicht. Ah, du bist fester. Okay, dann ist es also, ihr kriegt dann auch ein Gehalt unabhängig davon oder du bekommst ein Gehalt unabhängig davon, ob du jetzt Aufträge hast oder nicht, sozusagen. Also das ist wahrscheinlich gut ausgelastet sein. Aber wie ist es bei dir, Thorsten, als Freelancer?
Also der grießt bei dir für 800.
Naja, also ich arbeite hauptsächlich für Firmen, die sich in dem Feld spezialisiert haben und handeln natürlich mit denen halt schon ganz individuelles, ganz individuellen Tagesrats aus. Ist jetzt nicht sicherlich nicht das, was die Firma dann vom Kunden selber bekommt.
Einmal über das ganze Boulevardesk. Habt ihr euch schon mal den Spaß gegönnt, einfach mal über den Daumen auszurechnen oder zu fabulieren, wie lange ihr unterwegs seid oder unterwegs werdet, um beispielsweise ein Windows XP mal auf Herz und Nieren zu prüfen? Wie lange würde man da brauchen, wenn es nicht längst schon mal irgendwer, na ja offensichtlich nicht.
Was heißt offensichtlich nicht, das würde ich jetzt so nicht unterschreiben. Also ich denke schon, dass du dann mit einem zehn Mann Teams und halbes Jahr unterwegs bist.
Das ist eigentlich ja gar nicht leistbar, oder?
Wär ich vorsichtig.
Also es gibt wirklich, das wird tatsächlich gemacht.
Hängt sehr davon ab. Ich meine, das ist dann am Ende vom Tag wirklich das Problem des Auftraggebers, weil es gibt keine Berechnungsvorschriften, wie viel Security Kosten darf. Das heißt der Auftraggeber muss das selber für sich rausfinden und dann kann das durchaus sein, dass in der Planung rauskommt, okay, das lohnt sich.
Gibt es eigentlich noch Jobs, die besser bezahlt werden, als Security Consultants in der IT-Branche? Ich hab ja mal so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das so...
Na Moment, die sind teuer, die werden nicht gut bezahlt.
Das ist so ziemlich das obere Ende ist von dem, was man so mit legalen Jobs irgendwie verdienen kann, hab ich ja manchmal das Gefühl.
Nee, richtig gute Leute in der Entwicklung sind sehr, sehr viel teurer.
Vor Nachrichten noch ein bisschen Musik von Thorsten. Shitkicker von Wie Hast Du die Band?
Ben Fritz in Panko, dann 102, 6.
Eine nacht halb 12.
Fritz Info.
In der Nacht ist es locker bewölbt und trocken, die Temperaturen kühlen sich ab auf 15 bis 9 Grad. Morgen ist es dann in der Uckermark anfangs teils wolkig, später überall sonnig und es soll nicht regnen. Bei 26 bis 29 Grad die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Nach dem Wahldebakel in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat der Landesvorstand der SPD angekündigt, geschlossen zurückzutreten. Dies gab der bisherige Landesvorsitzende Schartau in Düsseldorf bekannt. Schartau trat heute zurück. Der Vorstand wird am 9. Juli folgen. Neuer Parteichef soll der bisherige Finanzminister Diekmann werden. In Hannover hat der 30. Deutsche Evangelische Kirchentag begonnen. Zum Eröffnungsgottesdienst kamen mehrere 10.000 Menschen, darunter auch Bundeskanzler Schröder und Bundespräsident Köhler. Die Veranstalter erwarten auf dem fünftägigen Kirchentag mehr als 100.000 Teilnehmer. Nach einem Brand in der Berliner Galeria Kaufhof am Alexanderplatz mussten zwei Personen mit Rauchvergiftungen ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert werden. Nach Angaben der Feuerwehr war bei Bauarbeiten Isoliermaterial in Brand geraten. Zehn Löschfahrzeuge und zusätzliche Sonderfahrzeuge mit insgesamt rund 70 Feuerwehrleuten waren im Einsatz. In Istanbul fand das Finale der Fußball Champions League statt. Nach der Verlängerung stand es im Spiel Mailand gegen Liverpool 3 zu 3. Vor wenigen Sekunden endete das Elfmeterschießen. Liverpool hat gewonnen im Elfmeterschießen mit 3 zu 2. Der Verkehr fritt mit einer Meldung von der A24 in die Ringrichtung Schwerin zwischen Wittstock, Dosse und Parchim ein Schwerlasttransport überholt nicht möglich.
Vielen Dank Matthias Kerkov, drei Minuten nach halb zwölf.
Wieder, wieder, wieder, wieder einmal wandelt er auf unergründlichen und genial überraschenden Solopfaden. 2001 erschien sein erstes Soloalbum Endlich Urlaub. In diesem Jahr folgte das zweite mit dem Titel Am Ende der Sonne. Ist er unterwegs auf der Sonnenblume auf DevTour 2005 und natürlich spielt er auch in Berlin. Kurz präsentiert Farin Urlaub.
Und das wäre sie hoffnungslose Technik, Niete.
Im Unterverzeichnis des Gibson arbeitet jemand echt auf Hochtouren. Wir haben eine Person online, aber die Arbeitsbelastung entspricht etwa zehn. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Hacker.
Und Hacker haben wir im Studio, Chaosradio 102 hier auf Fritz. Traumberuf Hacker, Fragezeichen, ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung und zwei, die diesen Traumberuf oder vermeintlichen Traumberuf ausüben, sind im Studio, nämlich TAS und FX.
Also man kann von Leben, wenn man Hunger hat, ne, geht so.
Also wir sind ja vor den Nachrichten, haben wir ja gesprochen über so Tagessätze. Und wenn ich das so höre, denke ich halt schon, dass es zumindest finanziell ein Traumberuf ist. Ist es denn verdient tatsächlich jeder so viel oder gibt es da auch Unterschiede? Oder ist das Geld oder verdient jeder, also hat jeder verdient diesen Tagessatz qualitativ?
Achso, du meinst, haben alle verdient, was sie kriegen.
Genau.
Naja, was sie dann selbst persönlich kriegen, ist ja dann noch was anderes, wenn er angestellt ist. Na, es ist schon ein Unterschied und das merkt man dann auch schon. Also wie unsere lieben Süddeutschen Landesdingsbums sagen würden, mit Bürger genau sagen würden ist du kriegst halt nur was du bezahlst. Und das heißt halt auch es gibt verschiedene Dinge, es gibt ja völlig verschiedene Tätigkeiten. Also wir brechen ja nicht nur in Netze ein, es gibt ja ein sehr breites Spektrum. Und je nachdem was man da macht und wie lange das dauert, sind dann halt auch die Kosten.
Gibt es denn so Liedhacker und Hilfshacker oder wie ist das aufgeteilt? Hätte man gerne. Wo macht sich das fest dran? Also wie entscheiden die Firmen? Wie viel sie jemanden an Gehalt zahlen? Was sind da die Kriterien dafür? Oder wenn jetzt TS in den Verhandlungen geht, sagt er, ich hätte jetzt gerne Betrag X pro Tag, weil ich kann und... Ja, oder wo sozusagen würdet ihr eure Qualifikation festmachen oder wie machen eure Arbeitgeber die Qualifikation fest?
Na ja, meistens orientiert sich das schon irgendwie an den Vorstellungen, die eben der Kunde hat. Also in meinem Fall, wenn ich engagiert werde für irgendeine andere Firma, die haben halt ihre Standardsätze für externe Mitarbeiter. Und da kann ich dann halt sagen, okay oder nicht okay. Also wenn ich, ja, kann ich eigentlich so gar nichts zu sagen.
Nee, aber ich meine, verdient tatsächlich da gleich viel oder macht die Qualifikation auch einen Unterschied?
Ich denke schon. Also ich meine, jemand, der gerade mal einen Portscanner bedienen kann, was soll man ihm zahlen?
Also es ist tatsächlich, ich würde gerade fragen, dafür gibt es Geld?
Ja, bei manchen Leuten gibt es dafür Geld. Es ist halt tatsächlich auch bei den Tagessätzen unterschiedlich für was du tust, was es kostet. Also dann kommt es auch nicht mehr so auf die Person an. Das kann durchaus sein, dass eine Person, die doch sehr viel kann und ein sehr breites Spektrum hat und auch technisch sehr gut ist, mal einen weniger anspruchsvollen Auftrag erledigt. Und zumindest wenn man ein Angestellter ist, passiert es dann durchaus, dass der Kunde für diesen Auftrag einen völlig anderen Tagessatz für dich bezahlt, als wenn du was sehr Anspruchsvolles tust.
Und wie wissen die Firmen, wie funktioniert das? Gibt es da so eine Art Job? Oder wie finden die Security Consultants zu den Firmen? Oder wie finden die Firmen die Security Consultants? Gibt es da irgendwie einen Markt? Gar nicht.
Es gibt keine mehr.
Also gut, aber irgendwie, ihr seid jetzt auch hingekommen. Also seid jetzt durch euren Ruf, habt ihr euch einen Ruf gemacht? Oder habt ihr eine Webseite oder ist es der Name, der bekannt ist? Wie gehen die Firmen da auf Suche, auf Kandidatensuche?
Also oft ist es ja genau andersrum. Oft ist es ja so, dass die Leute sich in den Firmen, die Firmen sind ja meistens nicht reine Profi-Hackerfirmen, sondern bieten auch andere Dinge an. Und es ist häufig so, dass Leute sich in den Firmen entwickeln und besser werden. Außerdem hat man nicht so die Wahl, weil richtig gute Leute kriegt man nicht mehr. Also wir haben einen Nachwuchs von exakt Null.
Das ist ein echtes Problem.
How come?
Also ich meine, wenn ich mir angucke, wie hier, als wir gesagt haben Traumberuf Hacker, wie hier die Telefonleitungen angefangen haben zu glühen quasi, wo lauter junge Menschen angerufen haben, die wissen wollten, wie man Hacker wird, kann ich mir nicht, warum gibt es einen Nachwuchs?
Super anspruchsvoll.
Also nicht jeder, der irgendwie meint, ein Hacker zu sein oder gerne Hacker lernen will, ist halt halt, wie halt auch schon im Ankündigungstext beschrieben, ist halt gut als Security Consultant. Da gehört ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Was gehört dazu?
Na ja, da gehört auf jeden Fall dazu, dass man seine Arbeit sehr ausführlich dokumentiert.
Also das ist gar nicht Hacker-like.
Das heißt, das ist eher Teamplay?
Ja, und man arbeitet halt auch oft im Team, man muss teamworkfähig sein. Man muss halt ein ziemlich breites Wissensspektrum haben und das kriegt man eigentlich halt eben durch eine lange Berufserfahrung in anderen Berufsfeldern wie Systemadministration oder als Programmierer. Also wenn man über diesen Bereich einiges gemacht hat und da ein bisschen Erfahrung hat, dann ist das auf jeden Fall schon ziemlich positiv. Also ohne Berufserfahrung als Systemadministrator bringt dir das gar nichts, dich eben so als Security Consultant zu bewerben irgendwo, weil was machst du, wenn du denn so einen Rechner aufgemacht hast vom Kunden? Also du bist dann irgendwie auf der Kiste drauf, aber weißt gar nicht, was jetzt hier Unix prompt, was mache ich damit? Das nützt dir nichts.
Ich bin jetzt gut und jetzt?
Dann bist du halt auf dem Rechner meinetwegen drauf, aber du weißt gar nicht, dass du noch viel mehr Informationen sammeln kannst auf dem System, um noch ein ganzes Netzwerk, was dahinter liegt, aufzumachen oder zu testen, wie auch immer.
Das ist jetzt der technische Hintergrund. Also ein breites Backgroundwissen auf der technischen Seite braucht man auf jeden Fall. Da gehen wir dann glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen mehr ins Detail ein. Was aber relativ wichtig ist, ist halt, dass man gemeinen Consulting Skills nennt. Also es heißt der Security Consultant und das ist ja, wie Frank so salopp mit dem Schlips und Anzug beschrieben hat, durchaus auch eine Beraterrolle. Also man ist eigentlich schon auch ein Berater im klassischen Sinne. Also genau wie die Menschen in Anzug, von denen man nie weiß was sie tun, die nur ohne Ende Geld kosten.
Der klassische Nerd ist da schon fast aufgeschmissen, weil er zu hermetisch unterwegs ist oder?
Na man ist tatsächlich auch in die Geschäftsprozesse sehr eingebunden. Also man muss schon auch verstehen, was diese Unternehmen denn so tun, wo ihre Geschäftsprozesse liegen, was die einzelnen Motivationen auch von der einzelnen Person sind, in was für einem Klima man sich befindet. Also ob da jetzt jemand jemand anderen an den Kahn fahren will oder nicht. Man will ja auch nicht irgendwie missbraucht werden. Das kann ja sehr schnell passieren und es wäre auch schlecht für den professionellen Ruf.
Also beides ist zum Beispiel Firma oder Abteilung A beauftragt oder sie leiert halt an, dass irgendwie Abteilung B, die sich sowieso nicht leiden können, halt einen Sicherheitscheck bekommt und die damit irgendwie gnadenlos auf die Nase fallen würden, weil sie das vermuten zum Beispiel. Oder halt irgendwelche Rivalitäten innerhalb von Firmen, von Abteilungen oder sowas.
Kompetenzrang allein innerhalb von Unternehmen und so.
Ist das tatsächlich ein Problem, dass der Nachwuchs ausbleibt oder? Ich meine, ihr seid jetzt beide nicht wirklich alt. Also ihr tretet ja nicht in fünf Jahren ab. Also eigentlich solltet ihr euch doch freuen und sagen hehehehe, ich verdiene mich dumm und dusselig.
Ja, das hilft dir nur so lange, wie es nicht ungefähr zehnmal so viel Bedarf gibt, wie du Angebot hast. Weil dann haben die Leute irgendwann keine Lust.
Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, sitzen Arbeiterhause zu Hause und denken sich okay, okay, okay, wo fange ich an? Wo fange ich an? Wo fange ich an? Sagen wir denen das heute noch? Wir gehen nochmal in unsere. Okay, also Johannes Bekerner ist als Moderator überbezahlt. Das wissen wir seit die Titanic diese Aktion gestartet hat. Jetzt möchte Johannes Bekerner gerne Hacker werden bzw. Security Consultant. Im Anzug sieht er ganz hübsch aus, reden kann er auch. Das hat er im Fernsehen unter Beweis bestellt. Welches Buch kauft er sich jetzt? Also wo fängt er an?
Na das kannst du wirklich vergessen. Also da muss schon richtig viel technischer Background von vornherein da sein, bevor man überhaupt in diese Richtung geht.
Studium?
Informatik?
Ist eine Möglichkeit.
Auf jeden Fall ein Anfang. Also nicht jeder, der ein Studium der Informatik erfolgreich abgeschlossen hat, ist jetzt gleich geeignet für diesen Beruf.
Gibt es nicht irgendeine Aufbaustudiengänge oder irgendwelche Studiengänge?
Es gibt Universitäten, die nehmen dieses Thema ziemlich ernst. Also zum Beispiel die RHTW Aachen, RWTH. Die machen ziemlich viel zu dem Thema.
Also ich weiß in Cambridge gibt es glaube ich auch ein paar ziemlich fitte Leute.
Also das ist halt aber jetzt auch nicht so global. Das machen halt Unis so unter sich. Wenn sich dann ein Professor findet, der das Thema interessant und spannend findet und auch wichtig findet, dann findet da schon was zu statt und das ist schon ziemlich positiv, weil das ist auch relativ neu. Aber ansonsten kann man sagen, dass das nicht so besonders viel oder halt nicht besonders groß beachtet wird im Informatikstudium. Es gibt zwar Vorlesungen zu Security Engineering und Qualitätssicherung und sowas, aber gewisse wichtige Aspekte bleiben da auf jeden Fall aus und vor, denke ich.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist sowieso einfach Erfahrung sammeln und einfach machen. Sachen Code angucken, Code lesen, sich das Thema angucken.
Das sowieso.
Aus Fehlern lernen.
Und da möglichst alles aus. Es gibt keinen Basiswissen Security Consultant.
Also es gibt schon Basiswissen. Ich würde sagen, es gibt schon Basiswissen Consultant. Erstmal egal, was man macht, das beinhaltet, dass man mindestens mit Windows und Unix Plattformen klarkommt. Und zwar anständig. Also auch.
Also klarkommt im Sinne von klarkommt.
Genau. Man muss nicht irgendwie alles in fünf Minuten ans Laufen kriegen. Aber man muss auf jeden Fall schon wissen, wie das funktioniert und auch die Konzepte dahinter verstanden haben. Das ist schon relativ wichtig, dass man auch so Sicherheitskonzepte versteht oder überhaupt ein Gesamtkonzept von so einem Betriebssystem es halt nicht nur benutzen kann. Und wenn du dann in die Richtung Security-Konseiten gehst, muss eigentlich eine Programmiersprache da sein. Also es muss mindestens eine vorzugsweise C. Also ich habe immer den Eindruck, wenn die Leute eine Sprache richtig programmieren können, dann können sie programmieren und dann ist alles andere relativ schnell da.
Visual Basic ist wahrscheinlich nicht so ein guter Einstieg.
Ok, beschränken wir uns auf Sprachen, die zumindest in eine Intermediate-Language übersetzt werden.
Und man sollte wissen, was eine Intermediate-Language ist. Ja. Also das brauch ich schon mal gar nicht anzufangen. Angenommen, ich könnte das jetzt, dann werde ich reich, ja? Nein. Also es gibt zehnmal so viele Nachfrage wie Angebot an Security-Consultants. Wenn ihr nicht mit 40 euch zur Ruhe setzen könnt, dann habt ihr irgendwas falsch gemacht, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Naja, nicht wirklich. Ich meine, es gibt halt Berufe, die werden halt, da kriegt man halt vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass man dann auch unter den gleichen Bedingungen arbeitet, wie zum Beispiel ein Friseur, wo wir vorhin das Thema hatten. Also nach Feierabend hört das einfach nicht auf mit dem Arbeiten zum Beispiel. Also man muss ja auch ein bisschen Eigeninitiative mit reinbringen, um halt auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben. Während der Arbeit selber, wenn man fest angestellt ist, hat man unter Umständen auch nicht so die Möglichkeit, sich auf dem Laufenden zu halten und halt Papers zu lesen, die jetzt für einen privat interessant sind und so was alles. Also man muss halt schon sehr viel dafür tun.
Wenn ihr jetzt so einen Auftrag habt, irgendwie meinetwegen in Frankfurt, dann heißt es wahrscheinlich irgendwie montags mit der 6 Uhr Maschine, Juchthansa, Touristenklasse. Erster Klasse.
Touristenklasse.
Ja, das kommt halt auch dazu. Das ist eine Menge Stress, den man halt dadurch auch hat. Der halt jetzt nicht besonders vergütet wird oder so. Das ist dann halt all inclusive. Man hat halt den Stress, man muss um 6 Uhr am Flughafen stehen, weil um 7 Uhr die Maschine geht, dann muss man vom Flughafen.
Ich kann dir aus dem Stand 20 Leute nennen, die jetzt sagen, mir kommen die Tränen. Und die stehen alle genau um diese Uhrzeit an der Stanze und stanzen irgendwas.
Ja, die sind dann aber auch um 15 Uhr fertig.
Die haben, die machen dann Schluss und, oder um 16 Uhr.
Noch mit einer Stunde tarifvertraglicher Mittagspause.
Gut und kriegen dafür aber einen Bruchteil. Hier ist Chaosradio 102 auf Fritz in Blumenhune heute Abend und um den Beruf Security Consultant, Sicherheitsberater gleichsam, also Berufshacker geht es heute Abend und die 0331 77 97 110 angerufenen, das ist die Fritz-Hotline, hat es Skusi.
Ja ich wollte noch mal kurz ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, wie so das Anforderungsprofil aussieht und mit was man es da so zu tun hat in dem Job von wegen Traumberuf, also ich meine es ist schon irgendwo ein Traumberuf, aber es hat halt auch irgendwie echt harte Anforderungen. Also ich meine was schon gesagt wurde, man braucht halt den technischen Durchblick, man muss technisch irgendwie in der Lage sein beurteilen zu können, wie sicher ist dieses System, was kann da alles schiefgehen, wo fange ich an, wie gehe ich vor. Man muss in der Lage sein, das ordentlich dokumentieren zu können, das alles aufschreiben zu können, das eben auch sprachlich dementsprechend formulieren zu können, dass das in so einer Vorstandsabteilung oder wo auch immer es dann landet, irgendwie verstanden wird bzw. vorlegbar und vorzeigbar ist. Ich meine, dass es, wie Thorsten glaube ich vorhin schon gesagt hat, das Produkt, was der Kunde letztendlich kauft. Je nachdem in welchem Bereich man so arbeitet, wenn man international tätig ist, irgendwie muss man das alles noch auf Englisch können. Dann muss man, wie auch schon eben angeklungen ist, als letztes vor der Musik irgendwie dazu bereit sein, eben morgens aufzustehen, irgendwie auf der Matte zu stehen, um die halbe Welt zu fliegen, um dann da mal eine Woche zu leben.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, aber was du da beschreibst, also ich sagte eben schon mal, ich kann ja aus dem Stand zehn Leute nennen, für die wäre das ein paradiesischer Zustand.
Ja, das ist aber auch wirklich immer nur eine Woche lustig, oder vielleicht vier Wochen sein, aber wenn du echt irgendwie die Hälfte deiner Zeit irgendwie da in irgendwelchen Flughäfen verbringst.
Ja, du kannst aber auch die Hälfte deiner Zeit an irgendeiner Stanze stehen. Ich finde, das ist schon jammern auf hohem Niveau, was ich hier gerade höre.
Aber irgendwie 16 Stunden Arbeitstage sind halt auch auf Dauer immer nicht so lustig.
Das mag sein.
Also immer hierhin zu brechen.
Ja, also gut, das mag ja für manchen auch gar nicht so schlimm sein. Und sagt sich, na ja, um 6 Uhr aufstehen tue ich auch sonst irgendwie, kein Problem. Also ich meine, was braucht man noch irgendwie? Man muss natürlich das Ganze auch irgendwie auf, man muss ein bisschen auftreten können und sich so einem Kunden gegenüber verhalten können. Also wie vorhin ja auch schon mal kurz angeklungen ist, manchmal muss man da in Anzug und Schlips und Kragen hin und dann sitzt man da irgendwo in einer Besprechung, in irgendeinem Vorstand und die wollen halt wissen, okay, wie sieht es denn aus? Was habt ihr denn gefunden? Was macht unsere Software oder unsere Server oder sonst was da denn so? Sowas muss man natürlich auch über die Bühne bekommen und muss sowas können.
Was ist denn da so ein schöner klassischer Fauxpas, die man sich leisten kann, wenn man da mit zum Kunden sitzt? Habt ihr da irgendwie eine nette Anekdote vielleicht? Ist da schon mal passiert sowas, wo er sagt, uups, wo dich alle irgendwie angucken, ganz mit großen Augen und du weißt jetzt, das hättest du besser nicht sagen sollen?
Mir fällt da so speziell jetzt grad nichts an, aber Sachen mit anderen Ländern, wo man halt irgendwelche Sitten nicht kennt und da in gefährliche Situationen geraten kann.
Chaos Radio 102. Wenn ich höre, der Konzertenbereich ist sehr wichtig, ich muss eben auch dem Kunden angemessen gegenüber treten können, weil es sich im Zweifelsfall auch um weltweit operierende Konzernen handelt. Das ist dann auch nichts für junge Leute eigentlich dieser Beruf, oder?
Vor allem nichts für den klassischen Nerd, der halt irgendwie mit Kapuzenpulli irgendwie sich die Nächte mit Pizza und Cola um die Ohren schlägt, was eigentlich das typische Hacker-Bild ist, wie man es sofort hört.
Viele Leute finden das einfach uncool und machen es aus Prinzip nicht. Also ich hab schon von ein paar Leuten das gesehen, dass mich das sehr überrascht hat. Vor allem da wir ja genau dieses Personalproblem haben. Bist du dann mal mit Leuten irgendwo auf einem Projekt, wo du jetzt nicht die beruflichen Hintergründe kennst und denkst, naja, ob die das jetzt hinkriegen und so. Weil du kennst sie nur als Nerds. Und man sieht dann schon, wenn jemand da mal Bock drauf hat, das mal anständig zu machen, dass sie das dann auch mal können.
Verzeihen die Kunden auch, ich sag mal, also verzeihen die Kunden, dass du vielleicht ein unsicheres Consultant auftreten hast, dafür, dass du... Den Nerd-Bonus? Ja, genau, Nerd-Bonus. Also einfach der Sachverstand, dass der das ausgleicht.
Ja, wenn der Bericht korrekt ist, was ja letztlich eben das Ergebnis ist, was der Kunde in den Händen hält. Und wenn der Kunde zufrieden ist, ja, warum nicht?
Gibt es das auch, dass die Leute dann immer Schwachstellen quasi bewusst einbauen und gucken, ob ihr die denn findet? Gibt es da was, dass sie euch ein bisschen aufs Glatteis führen wollen oder mal auf die Probe stellen?
Das ist ein Sat1-Hackertüv.
Ist mir persönlich noch nicht untergekommen, aber es gibt schon hin und wieder mal so Hinweise. Ja, da haben wir schon mal irgendwie, da wissen wir, dass es da nicht ganz so gut ist und so. Da werden sie ja wahrscheinlich selber drauf kommen. Also sowas gibt es dann schon mal.
Aber ist es denn eher so als kleine Attacke gedacht oder ist das so ein Widerstand oder ist das eher um die Leute? Also wie reagieren die auf euch, wenn ihr da ankommt?
Hängt auch sicherlich wieder davon ab, was man genau macht, was man da machen soll. Also bei so internen Netzwerk Audits beim Kunden vor Ort arbeitet man viel mit den Systemadministratoren zusammen oder unter Umständen halt auch mit Programmierern, die da Sachen entwickeln, die da erreichbar sind. Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Entweder absolut gute Kooperation zwischen Systemadministration und uns oder die stellen halt so auf Stur, weil die halt das Gefühl haben, sie werden verantwortlich dafür gemacht, wenn Sicherheitsmängel aufgetreten sind und wir die finden, dann reagieren die manchmal auch ein bisschen komisch.
Unbeliebt seid ihr auch noch?
Würde ich so nicht sagen. Also in den meisten Fällen ist eigentlich das Echo immer sehr positiv. Gerade so von Systemadministratoren, die sind sehr interessiert, wollen auch was lernen und das ist auch der ganze Sinn dieser Geschichte. Also wir gehen ja dann nirgendwo hin und nehmen irgendwas auseinander, um zu bewirken, dass irgendwelche Leute gefeuert werden, weil sie schlecht gearbeitet haben. Wir helfen auf jeden Fall dabei, den Sicherheitsstandard zu erhöhen und eben halt auch die Leute zu schulen, die das Ganze verwalten und betreuen. Weil die können halt auch nicht alles wissen und wir finden halt mal irgendwelche Punkte und sagen, so damit solltet ihr euch ein bisschen auseinandersetzen und das könnt ihr da so besser machen und so weiter. Also die hat eigentlich jeder was davon.
Hör mal, willst du zur Elite gehören? Dann musst du mit Verstand hacken und nicht unkontrolliert. Wenn du wirklich einen echten Hack machen willst, dann solltest du den Gibson One enjoy. Ihr wisst schon, das sind die Computer, die sie in der Medizin einsetzen und bei der Suche nach Öl und so. Das kannst du vergessen, die Sicherheitsvergierungen sind zu eng. Sowas knackst du nicht. Schon möglich, aber wenn ich in ein Heavy Metal System rein will, dann versuch ich durch die Hintertür, wo die Sicherheitsstufen leichter zu umgehen sind.
Hier ist Chaosradio 102, Traumberuf Hacker, beziehungsweise Untraumberuf Security Consultant, das Thema heute Abend. Zu Gast haben wir zwei Security Consultants, zwei von 20, die eigentlich gebraucht würden, wenn ich das eben richtig verstanden habe. Kann man sich irgendwo hinwenden, wenn man meint, man sei Nachwuchs? Auch an die Firmen, die es ohnehin schon anbieten, oder?
Einfach eine Bewerbung schreiben. Ich bin Nerd und will gerne Security Consultant werden.
Ich bin Nerd und wäre gern Lead.
Im Zweifelsfall schon, ja.
An welche Firmen wendet man sich?
Man sucht sich eine aus.
Zum Beispiel an deine.
Für welche Arbeit so? N-Runs GmbH ist das.
N-Runs.
Wie seid ihr denn jetzt konkret, also ihr beide zu den Jobs gekommen, ganz kurz beworben oder gefragt worden?
Na, ich hab vorher schlicht mal gerade von Netzwerk Consulting gearbeitet und in der selben Firma gab es halt auch Leute, die Security gemacht haben, noch nicht so technisch und das ist dann sozusagen mit und um mich herum gewachsen. Das war ganz flauschig.
Torsten?
Ja, jetzt konkret als Security Consultant. Also das war mehr oder weniger auch eben Fragen, so nicht gefragt werden, aber Fragen, okay.
Seid ihr eigentlich käuflich? Also wie ist das, wenn jemand kommt und sagt, guck mal, dring doch mal da hinten ein. Ich meine, natürlich werdet ihr sagen nein, aber wie hoch müsste ein Preis sein, um so was zu machen?
Das machst du genau einmal.
Dann hast du niemanden mehr, der dich betalt als Arbeitnehmer und wahrscheinlich auch ohne Ende gesetzliche Probleme.
Aber wie ist denn das? Wir hatten ja schon gesagt, man braucht ziemlich viel Erfahrung, Skills, um einfach diesen Job machen zu können. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie programmieren können, ich muss dies und jenes sein. Ich muss möglicherweise auch in der Szene, Anführungszeichen, wie auch immer, unterwegs sein. Das heißt, ich muss ein bisschen auf dem Laufenden sein. Was sind so die aktuellen Sicherheitslücken? Was lohnt sich tendenziell mal anzugucken? Wo liegen die Probleme? Wenn ihr da seid, seid ihr das quasi als privaten Menschen oder tretet ihr da auch? Wie teilt sich das so? Diese Privatleben, Hacker sein, Anführungszeichen und jobmäßig. Wie sieht das bei euch aus? Ist das eins? Trennt ihr das oder?
Kann man gar nicht so genau trennen, glaube ich, weil wenn man eben das Gefühl hat, sich bei einer bestimmten Sache irgendwie weiterzubilden und vielleicht selber aktiv so ein bisschen Research betreibt, findet das wohl doch hauptsächlich in der eigentlichen Freizeit statt. Aber wenn es eben wichtig ist für einen selber und für den Beruf, den man ausübt, dann macht man das halt.
Davon wird man noch wahnsinnig, oder? Ich mein, du hast es wahrscheinlich noch besser, Fx, weil du Angestellt bist. Kannst du nach Hause gehen und sagen, so jetzt ist die Arbeitszeit zu Ende? Oder ist das einfach so ein romantisches Bild vom Angestelltenverhältnis von früher, was ich da hab?
Ich glaube der einzige Unterschied zwischen Angestelltenverhältnis und Freelancing ist, dass du ein festes Gehalt hast.
Und sozialversichert bist.
Weniger Probleme als Verbankers.
Nein, also es ist nichts mit Feierabend.
Wie ist es mit Firmen, die jetzt glauben, sie holen sich Hacker ins Haus? Also wir hatten ja vorhin das schon angesprochen, also es muss einfach Vertrauen da sein. Gibt es ja irgendwie eine Möglichkeit dieses Vertrauen zu vermitteln oder das irgendwie zu ja zu forcieren? Also forcieren kann man Vertrauen nicht, aber zu sagen, wie kann man das Vertrauen möglicherweise steigern oder wie kann man dem Kunden klar machen, dass wenn wir jetzt was gefunden haben, das auch wirklich da vertraulich bleibt und dass die Leute, die jetzt für uns arbeiten, die möglicherweise als echt gute Hacker in Anführungszeichen bekannt sind, das Wissen auch nicht anderweitig nutzen. Also gibt es denn oder seid ihr schon mal in Versuchung gekommen, das möglicherweise zu nutzen oder irgendwelche wie geht ihr mit dem Wissen um, was ihr da erfahrt oder lernt?
Ach, das ist ja, also es teilt sich ja in faktisches Wissen, dass du weißt, wie du irgendwo reinkommst, aber das weißt du ja deswegen, weil du es getestet hast, das heißt die Leute wissen das jetzt auch. Und dann gibt es so generelles Wissen, also du hast einfach mal wieder was Neues gesehen, eine neue Infrastruktur, du hast jetzt zum ersten Mal mit GSM Netzen innen gespielt oder es gibt einfach auch genügend viel spannendes Zeugs zu sehen und das erste, dieses faktische Wissen bringt ja eigentlich nicht viel. Es ist sehr schnell ausgetimt, weil die Leute werden es einfach mal fixen und auf der anderen Seite, wenn du es verwenden würdest, wäre es halt kriminell, würde dein Job gefährden, ist nicht so besonders smart, aber es gibt genügend andere spannende Dinge, an denen man sich freuen kann und mit denen man sich beschäftigen kann.
Ist es so, dass wenn man sich das Thema einmal legal im Auftrag angeschaut hat, dass es dann eigentlich auch uninteressant geworden ist? Also ist halt nicht mehr so eine heiße Kartoffel oder irgendwie unbedingt ein Ziel, wo ich jetzt vielleicht vor dem Auftrag gesagt hätte, okay, da hack ich jetzt mal aus Spaß. In dem Moment, wo der Auftrag da ist, sage ich jetzt, okay, jetzt habe ich mir das angeguckt, ich sehe da sind die Sachen und das und das ist unsicher, das und das geht. Passiert das oder ist es so, dass die Sachen dann einfach uninteressant werden in dem Moment, wo ihr den Auftrag bekommt, das zu hacken?
Das kann man eigentlich schwer sagen, also in dem Moment ist es halt auch ein Kunde und den behandelt man auch als Kunden.
Also, weil ich kenne, kenne es natürlich auch aus dem Clubumfeld, dass wenn Leute sehen, CCC Hacker und sich dann halt auch nicht so sicher sind, ob sie denn da mit dem mit dem Mitarbeiter irgendwie einen guten Griff gemacht haben und dann man den Leuten vielleicht schon auch erklären muss, dass man halt einfach loyalist in den Leuten gegenüber und einfach sagt, okay, wir sind jetzt hier angestellt, wir haben jetzt Vertragsverhältnis und es ist jetzt einfach im Prinzip langweilig oder gibt es jetzt nichts mehr zu hacken? Wir sind jetzt hier offiziell hier und wir sind Partner. Wir arbeiten zusammen. Es ist eine Herausforderung von den Kunden sowas oder ist das schon eher noch ein Misstrauen auch immer?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ja, wir haben jetzt ein bisschen über die persönlichen Hintergründe gesprochen. Vielleicht gehen wir noch mal ein bisschen so dieses vom Nerd werden oder so nochmal. Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal dieses Berufsbild ein bisschen vielleicht nochmal genauer beschreiben. Das heißt also, ähm, gut, ich bewerbe mich über meinen Tag. Ich dachte, das wäre noch ein Hacker.
Nein, nein, nein, ach so.
Haben wir noch einen?
Einen Hacker?
Ja, gib mal was.
Dann kriegst du jetzt noch einen Hacker.
Ein Wurm und ein Virus?
Oh ja, schön.
Die schöne kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr erinnern.
Wo ein Virus verschwören uns? Ich glaube, es ist zum Schluss hin, oder?
Das dauert ewig und drei Tage, das zu hacken.
Ich hol mir einen Kaffee.
Nochmal, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel Nerd kann man eigentlich raushängen lassen, wieviel Nerd braucht es zu sein bei dem Job?
Technisch ist es schon spannend. Also es ist tatsächlich ein Nerdjob.
Ist es, trotz manchmal mit irgendwie schlipsigen Kunden da zu sein?
Ist es ausschließlich, Rest ist bloß, fällt halt an. Also der Spaß ist halt tatsächlich, dass du durchaus spannende Dinge tust. Es ist extrem abwechslungsreich. Auch der gleichbleibend hohe Anspruch ist halt angenehm, weil du machst halt nicht einen Job zehn Jahre lang und eigentlich ist der Anspruch immer der selbe und irgendwann hast du überhaupt keinen Bock mehr. Sondern es ist schon angenehm, dass man auch gefordert wird und mitdenken muss.
Ist es nicht so, dass du in irgendeinem Jahr schon das dritte Mal hast du schon wieder diesen blöden Code analysieren und immer wieder die gleichen Fehler, die wir hier finden?
Na klar, es gibt immer irgendwas Langweiliges, aber die Abwechslung überwiegt doch massiv.
Das gibt es tatsächlich, dass du immer wieder den gleichen Fehler findest.
Man möchte dann manchmal wirklich hingehen und so literally den Laptop nehmen und um die Ohren holen.
Was sind das typischerweise für Fehler? Ist das was, was ich verstehe?
Ist völlig egal, gibt es in jeder Art und Kulör. Leute verstehen halt manchmal einfach prinzipiell das Problem nicht und fixen halt immer nur die eine Stelle, die im Bericht aufgeführt wurde. Genau, also es gibt so eine großartige Geschichte, wo dann normalerweise man guckt halt, ob irgendwelche Sachen kaputtgehen, indem man viele A's hinschickt. Und es gibt so großartige Geschichten, wo dann Leute wirklich da hergegangen sind und halt geschaut haben, ob jemand große A's geschickt hat, nicht ob jemand zu viel geschickt hat, sondern ob jemand große A's geschickt hat.
Dann schickt man halt B's.
Dann schickt man halt B's, dann geht's wieder kaputt und dann denkt man auch so, Leute, habt jetzt.
Die Nummer der Fritzotline ist übrigens 0331-7097-110 und jemand, dessen Namen ich nicht wirklich auszusprechen weiß, hat angerufen, er fängt mit X an und hört mit X auf, sag ihn selbst.
Guten Abend, HPA-SRX.
Folgendes. Ich würde mich selber so ein bisschen als Nachwuchs in der Branche bezeichnen und wollte ein bisschen noch was dazu sagen, wo das Nachwuchsproblem eigentlich, woran das liegt.
Tja, woran?
Ich studiere im Moment was Informatik ähnliches.
Was Informatik ähnlich? Was denn?
Informationssystemtechnik. Das ist so eine Mischung aus Elektrotechnik und Informatik. Der theoretische Background ist zwar ganz hilfreich auch bei manchen Sachen, aber die akademische Informatik hat ziemlich wenig damit zu tun, was man denn am Ende können muss, wenn man irgendwelche Systeme auseinandernimmt oder da reinsteigen will. Also zum Beispiel hatten wir in einer Vorlesung auch Buffer-Overflows, wunderschönen Standard Stack-Base, aber der Vortragende, da hörte das dann auch auf. Also bei Hieb wusste er nicht weiter und...
Wozu brauche ich dann akademische Informatik?
Akademische Informatik braucht man, um schöne Algorithmen zu entwickeln und ja, die Mathematik dahinter zu verstehen. Aber nachher, wenn man dann irgendwo im Assembler-Code rumfrickeln muss, das lernt man nirgendwo im Studium. Das ist einfach Erfahrung, das ist sehr, sehr viel Arbeit.
Das heißt, die akademische Informatik ist die Hilfswissenschaft des Security Consulting?
Ja, ja. So in etwa.
Und woher kommt das Nachwuchsproblem?
Ja, daher. Das ist, alle meinen, Informatik lernen zu müssen. Wir kommen mit akademischer Informatik in Kontakt. Und durch Studium kommt man, wenn man eben alle Prüfungen dann irgendwie schafft. Und ja, aber es wird nicht in dieser, naja, hackermäßige Spieltrieb gefördert.
Und was hast du anders gemacht? Weil du sagst, du bezeichnest dich als Nachwuchs, studierst trotzdem Informatik?
Was hab ich anders gemacht? Bei mir war dieser Spieltrieb da so ein bisschen über meinen, über meinen Vater, der aus einem Sondermaschinenbau kam. Und ich bilde mir einfach mal ein, dass damals die Ausbildung noch ein bisschen anders gewesen sein muss. Oder zumindest die Erfahrung, die er im Beruf gesammelt hat.
Ich frage mich gerade, was Sondermaschinenbau, also was für Maschinen hat der gebaut?
Ich weiß, es ist oft Topic, aber Sachen, die nicht im Katalog stehen.
Angefangen von irgendwelchen Sonderverpackungsmaschinen, Hochgeschwindigkeitsstanzen, Weltuntergangsmaschinen. Ja, also irgendwelche verrückten Sachen.
Also Spieltrieb, Spieltrieb sagst du.
Spieltrieb, genau Spieltrieb.
Wo fängt der an? Wo hört der auf?
Der hört gar nicht auf.
Das heißt, du bist auch ein Spielkind noch.
Kann man den Spieltrieb ausleben in dem Job?
Nein, nicht in dem Job. Man braucht es privat, um die Motivation zu haben und sich da über fortzubilden.
Würde ich so unterschreiben.
Gute Nacht, danke für deinen Anruf. Also Spieltrieb ist wichtig und akademische Informatik ist gerade mal eine Hilfswissenschaft, habe ich gelernt. Micha aus Kreuzberg. Ja, du hast auch eine Frage?
Ja, eine Frage zu, oder besser gesagt, eine Aussage zu dem, was vorhin gesagt worden ist. Die meiste Beschreibung für diesen Job ist ja eigentlich Consulting erstmal mit einer Spezialisierung auf Security.
Halbe halbe. Also ich denke es ist wirklich halbe halbe, je nachdem wo man arbeitet, was man macht. Aber es ist schon ein massiver Consulting-Anteil dabei. Es gibt ja auch Fachbereiche, die gar nicht so technisch sind. Es gibt zum Beispiel das ganze Thema Security Management Audit. Da hat man sein Laptop wirklich zum E-Mail lesen und Text schreiben.
Oder stell dir vor du bist Datenschutzbeauftragter in einer Firma oder so was, denn bist du halt wahrscheinlich Jurist. Möglicherweise, was jetzt vielleicht nicht so ganz nah dran ist, aber im Prinzip ja auch für die Sicherheit der Datensicherheit verantwortlich in der Firma.
Aber es gibt tatsächlich Security Consultants, die Prozess Audits machen. Also sich wirklich mit den entsprechenden Security Managern und Datenschutzbeauftragten hinsetzen und schauen, okay, wisst ihr denn, was ihr hier tut?
Das sind dann so Sachen, die man analysieren und entwickeln und ausarbeiten.
Was mich vorhin noch eben dran erinnert hat, weil ihr eben eine ganze Weile beschrieben habt, dass man da eben auch hingeben muss, weil ich nicht sitzfegern, Sachen richtig kommunieren, dokumentieren, alles aufschreiben, im Vorfeld beschreiben, was man machen will, den Kunden verstehen, das übersetzen und so weiter. Das sind eigentlich alles so Fähigkeiten, die ein Consultant an den Tag legen muss. Weniger was mit Security zu tun hat. Im Endeffekt ist ja dann nachher die reine Arbeit, dann die Security.
Das ist durchaus korrekt, aber die reine Arbeit sollte halt möglichst auch gut sein.
Jaja, natürlich, um Gottes Willen, ganz klar. Wie geht denn ihr, habt ihr da mal so ein richtig schönes Beispiel, muss ja nicht aus der Praxis sein, sondern einfach mal so an den Hahn herbeigezogen, wie ihr an den Fall ran geht. Jetzt kommt eine Firma zu euch, der hat quasi 30 neue Anschlüsse in den Außenstellen und wir wissen, ob die jetzt sicher sind vor irgendwelchen Angriffen, weil diese Außenstellen gleich ins Internet mit angebunden wird. Die haben da einen VPN oder irgendwie sonst was. Wie geht er jetzt an diesen Kunden ran? Wie kriegt er es raus, was er genau haben will, im Sinne von auch, was er bezahlen kann?
Was er haben will, ist eigentlich erst mal die spannende Frage. Also man würde in dem Fall tatsächlich schon sich sehr viel länger unterhalten müssen. Da kommt es dann wirklich aufs Detail an. Also da kommt es halt wirklich darauf an. Wissen Sie denn, was Sie da verbaut haben? Steht das überhaupt schon? Oder geht es darum, sich ein Konzept anzugucken? Oder wissen Sie, was Sie verbaut haben, im Sinne von Geräten? Ist es irgendeine Neuerfindung? Weiß man irgendwas über das Gerät? Also zum Beispiel bei VPN weiß man über diese Endpunkte irgendwas, weil es ein großer Hersteller ist und man weiß, dass die ziemlich kaputt sind, weil es permanent irgendwelche Meldungen gibt oder dass sie ziemlich gut sind. Und was ist so Ihr Bedrohungsszenario? Also machen die Leute da direkt Internet? Wie kommt man da potenziell rein oder nicht? Manchmal muss man auch einfach sagen, okay, das lohnt sich jetzt nicht, das hier anzugucken. Aber das sind so die Hauptfragen, in denen man stellt und ich würde sagen dann daraus einen Plan machen.
Also in dem Gespräch steckt ja dann auch ab, was der Kunde im Endeffekt an Leistung von euch haben möchte.
Das ist eigentlich die Frage, was will er denn wirklich haben oder was braucht er denn wirklich? Und dann kann man ihm mal in der Hausnummer sagen, was es kostet. Dafür hat man dann aber auch wirklich Vertriebsleute. Also mich interessiert sowas gar nicht, was der Kunde dafür bezahlt. Das würde einfach meine Aussage darüber komprimentieren, was ich wichtig finde, was er kriegen sollte.
Und dann noch eine Frage. Macht ihr nur rein technische Antiffe oder macht ihr auch so ein Social Engineering? Also eigentlich mal so gucken, wie.
Ich war es nicht.
Interessante Frage trotzdem.
Na ja, also es kommt schon mal vor, dass man auch auf Social Engineering eine Menge Informationen bekommt, die einem echt unglaublich weiterhelfen. Bei technischen Sachen wiederum. Also irgendwie weiß ich, irgendwo eine E-Mail hinschicken, so ich hätte gern irgendwie den Source Code von der und dem, von dem und dem Skript, weil das habe ich schon immer gesucht und ich versuche gerade irgendwie, weiß ich, Y zu lernen. Und manchmal antworten die einem und schicken einem das, schreiben noch eine Dokumentation dazu. Ist natürlich echt prima.
Das ist auch richtig gut Ansatz. Ja, ich bin ja der Sicherheitsberater für Ihre Firma und wir bräuchten jetzt mal die Passwörter hier.
Oder halt, ja weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt Social Engineering ist oder so, aber du kommst auf eine Webseite, da steht drauf, wenn Sie nicht Mitarbeiter dieses Unternehmens sind, dann verlassen Sie diese Seite bitte. Ansonsten haben Sie hier die Möglichkeit, sich einzuloggen oder sich zu registrieren.
Das gibt's?
Wo? Und wenn dann halt irgendwie, wenn man sich danach registriert, dann weiß ich nicht, dann, wenn das dann auch irgendwie gegengelesen wird von irgendeinem Menschen, der das checkt und es dann irgendwie ein Act gibt und man kriegt eine E-Mail, hier sind Ihre Zugangsdaten zum Contentment-System sowieso. Das kommt in den Bericht rein? Unter Umständen.
Sollen wir die genug bezahlen?
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass das jetzt irgendwie verschwiegen werden soll oder so. Das ist vielleicht zum Teil auch gar nicht Teil der Untersuchung.
Aber gibt es denn, dass in den Untersuchungen in die Aufgaben reingeschrieben wird, rufen Sie mal hier die Mitarbeiter an oder fragen Sie mal den bei den Admins und kriegen Sie mal irgendwie was raus von denen.
Hatte ich noch nie.
Habe ich schon mal gehört, aber ich selber auch noch nicht.
Von Nachrichten noch kurz, André. André?
Jo, André.
Ich wollte einfach bloß mal meine Meinung zu dem Thema Wissen sagen und zwar finde ich, jeder, der irgendwo sich nicht weiterbildet, egal in welche Richtung er arbeitet, der bleibt irgendwo stehen, kommt nicht weiter voran und das ist sicherlich bei eurem Job genauso wie bei jedem anderen draußen auch. Egal ob er jetzt an einer CNC Maschine steht und irgendwelche Teile fräst oder im Prinzip Computersysteme schützt.
Besten Dank für das Statement, André. Aber auch mal, wie lang könnt ihr euch leisten, nicht am Ball zu bleiben? Also könnt ihr es euch leisten, ein halbes Jahr Urlaub zu machen oder seid ihr dann raus? Wie schnell geht da die Entwicklung?
Ich hab keine halbes Jahr Urlaub gemacht und kann das nicht beurteilen.
Gibt es keine größten Ordnungen bei der Mannheit?
Also ich würde sagen halbes Jahr Urlaub wäre zu viel.
Halbes Jahr wär schon zu viel.
Wenn Fritz in Schallockenburg, dann 102, 6.
Drei Minuten nach halb eins, Fritz Info.
In der Nacht ist es locker bewirbt bei 9 bis 15 Grad am Tage, dann in der Uckermark anfangs teils wolkig, später überall sonnig bei 26 bis 29 Grad. Und die Meldung jetzt mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Nach dem Wahldebakel in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat der Landesvorstand der SPD angekündigt, geschlossen zurückzutreten. Neuer Parteichef soll der bisherige Finanzminister Diekmann werden. Die SPD-Fraktion hat sich dafür ausgesprochen, mit Gerhard Schröder an der Spitze in den vorgezogenen Bundestagswahlkampf zu ziehen. Parteichef Müntefering schließt mittlerweile kleine Änderungen an der Arbeitsmarktreform Hartz IV nicht mehr aus. Die Innenminister der Länder und des Bundes haben sich auf ein Sicherheitskonzept für die Fußball-WM 2006 geeinigt. Noch nicht entschieden ist, ob das Schengener Abkommen ausgesetzt wird und ob es an den Grenzen Kontrollen geben wird. Der FC Liverpool hat in Istanbul das Champions League-Finale gegen den AC Mailand gewonnen. Sie besiegten die Italiener im Elfmeterschießen mit 3 zu 2. Nach regulärer Spielzeit und Verlängerung hat er es 3 zu 3 gestanden. Der Verkehr Fritz hat keine Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Sonntag ist Köln im Mellopark in Berlin. Friedrichshagener Straße 10, was ja auch Köbelnicker ist. Warum haben sie nichts an? Nun, das Wetter wird 30 Grad bringen und dort findet seit Freitag dann ein BMX Street and Dirt Contest statt. Highway to Hill. Mit Zelten, Liebhaben und jeder Menge internationaler BMX-Prominenz. Und weil richtig Stürzen bei lauter Musik noch mal noch mal so gut kommt, hat Ken FM für Sonntag zwei Bands im Gepäck. Bosse. Und Alias Caelan. Bosse und Alias Caelan, Sonntag bei Ken FM im Melo Park in Köpenick. Außerdem verschenken wir pro Stunde je zwei Karten für die RWW Konzertnacht und das Berlinova.
Was raten Sie mir?
Hör nicht auf deine Eltern, hör Ken FM.
Ken FM, die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen. Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr. Und im Radio heißt der Musik.
Fritz, leb dich mit dem Besten an und du stirbst wie alle.
Und das wäre sie, hoffnungslose Technik Nite.
Im Unterverzeichnis des Gibson arbeitet jemand echt auf Hochtouren. Wir haben eine Person online, aber die Arbeitsbelastung entspricht etwa zehn. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Hacker.
Womit wir auch wieder bei dem Nachwuchsproblem wären. Einer arbeitet für zehn. Du wolltest noch einen Satz zu akademischer Ausbildung loswerden.
Ja, das klang jetzt so ein bisschen so, als wenn du Geld verdienen willst, dann darfst du nicht zur Uni gehen und das ist halt nicht der Fall. Also ich denke mal, die Ausbildung, die akademische Ausbildung ist schon ein bisschen mehr auf produktiven und nicht auf destruktiven Einsatz ausgerichtet. Also wir sind ja schon darauf spezialisiert, Dinge auseinanderzunehmen. Das ist, wir haben jetzt gerade im Gespräch einen Vergleich gehabt. Das ist ungefähr so, als wenn du Chemie studierst, dann kriegst du halt den ganzen Unterbau, den du brauchst. Ob du jetzt danach zwei Komponentenkleber baust oder Waffen, ist erst mal relativ egal. Und naja, du lernst halt dann später oder auf irgendeinem anderen Wege, wie du deine Chemiekenntnisse im Waffenbau einsetzen kannst und arbeitest dann im Waffenbau.
Dir wird keiner beibringen, wie man C4-Sprengstoff baut, aber wenn du halt über das nötige Wissen verfügst und das da selber nochmal vertieft, dann kannst du das sicherlich auch ohne weiteres selber bauen.
Und über die notwendige kriminelle Energie, gehört da kriminelle Energie dazu bei dem was ihr macht auch irgendwo?
Nee, aber Spaß am Fehler finden auf jeden Fall.
Wir hatten ja diesen Begriff Spieltrieb gerade noch vor den Nachrichten. Kann ich dann irgendwie prüfen, ob ich diesen Spieltrieb hab oder kann ich ihn irgendwie forcieren oder kann ich ihn steigern oder mir bewusst machen, also wie kann ich erkennen, was jetzt dieser Spieltrieb ist?
Zauberwürfel unter drei Minuten.
Wo würdet ihr das festmachen, wie man den Spieltrieb hat? Gibt es da irgendwelche Indikatoren?
Nee, also wie du das für dich selber rausfinden kannst, da gibt es halt tatsächlich diverse Wege. Am themennächsten wären halt wirklich diese ganzen Hacker Games, was der Anrufer so ein bisschen andeuten wollte. Da gibt es ja schon ein paar mehr von. Da gibt es auch ein paar ganz gute. Kann man sich mal angucken, kann man mal ein bisschen mitspielen, kann man dann mal feststellen, okay, die werden dann immer schwieriger und die sind ja auch von Leuten gebaut worden. Also das ist ja schon ein bisschen realistisch. Und da kann man einfach sich mal einen Realitätsabgleich geben und dann mal gucken, ob man daran Spaß hat, wenn man irgendwo hängen bleibt und feststellt, man braucht jetzt mal zwei Wochen, um da weiterzukommen, ob man daran Spaß hat oder ob es einem halt nach drei Tagen echt aus dem Hals raus hängt.
Wo wir eben schon mal bei der akademischen Informatik waren, hat Marcel aus Karlsruhe auch noch eine Anmerkung.
Ja, Studium. Ich hab ja jetzt auch vor zwei Semestern angefangen zu studieren, mit vielen Freunden zusammen, die ich auch aus dem CCC umfällt könne. Und was mir halt häufig auffällt, ist, dass die Leute mit wirklich falschen Vorstellungen ins Studium reingehen und dann enttäuscht werden. Und ich kenn auch viele Hacker, die an der Uni versagt haben, weil sie, ich sag's mal so rum, mit dem universitären System nicht zurecht kamen. Also man kommt dahin und bei uns ist es halt oft so, dass man halt nicht wirklich so gefordert wird, wie man es gerne hätte. Also ja, man macht die ganze Zeit hier am Grundstudium nur Mathematik und ich glaub die Motivation von den Dozenten, das ist bei uns teilweise blanker Hohn. Also Vorlesung sieht so aus, Dozent kommt rein, legt Folie auf, legt nächste Folie auf, legt nächste Folie auf.
Warum machst du es dann?
Was soll ich sonst machen?
Ich kann ja sonst nichts. Ich mein, das Problem ist, ich denke bei uns gibt es halt auch keine Alternativen für jemanden, der sich da wirklich für interessiert, außer vielleicht eine Ausbildung, aber das ist vielleicht auch nicht der Anspruch.
Wenn es bei uns keine Alternativen gibt, warum gehst du nicht dahin, wo es Alternativen gibt?
Wo soll ich denn hingehen?
Weiß ich nicht, du sagst, bei uns gäbe es keine Alternativen.
Ich mein jetzt in Deutschland, weil ich denke, da haben wir immer noch das Problem, dass man irgendwie so, ich denke so, dass zwischendrin fehlt, weil eine Fachhochschule ist zum Beispiel eine sehr praktische Ausbildung, an der Universität eine sehr theoretische Ausbildung, aber ja, ich mein heute ist es ja, an der Universität sagt man zum Beispiel, Informatiker sind ja keine Programmierer. Was ich auch unterstreichen würde, aber das Problem ist halt, die Leute, die später gebraucht werden, die werden so auf diese Art und Weise gar nicht ausgebildet.
Wie ist es bei Security Firmen? Muss man da einen Uniabschluss haben? Wird es höher bewertet?
Ich glaube, die gehen eher nach den Fähigkeiten, die jemand mitbringt und nicht nach irgendwelchen Papieren, wo irgendwas bescheinigt wird, was irgendjemand mal bescheinigt hat.
Stimme ich zu, ist genau so. Also es ist wie überall in der Wirtschaft, wenn man Doktortitel hat, kriegt man halt prinzipiell erst mal 15 Prozent mehr, als man ohne kriegen würde. Also insofern würde es eine Rolle spielen, aber in den normalen, also ob du jetzt ein Diplome Informatiker bist oder nicht, spielt keine Rolle. Was eine Rolle spielt, ist halt was bei jeder Einstellung in jeder Branche eine Rolle spielt, ob du zum Beispiel mal eine Ausbildung zu Ende gemacht hast oder ob du fünf angefangen hast.
Jo, Hacker, haben wir heute darüber gesprochen. Wir wollen eigentlich jetzt zum Schluss, würde ich gerne oder so gerne Schluss, würde ich gerne noch mal ein, zwei lustige Anekdoten hören.
Genau.
Also wir brauchen ja wirklich keine Namen nennen und können ja auch ganz allgemein sind, aber nochmal von euch. So was war so das gruseligste, was ihr so hattet oder des obskurste vielleicht von jedem eine mal Geschichte?
Ja, einer muss anfangen.
Du hast weniger Berufshistorie, du musst nicht so lange überlegen.
Ja, was heißt gruselig? Also ich schlag gerne und oft die Hände über den Kopf zusammen, wenn ich irgendwie PHP Code lese. Ich habe dann immer den Eindruck, dass da Leute sitzen, die irgendwie aus Spaß mal angefangen haben PHP zu coden.
Und das ist nicht gern PHP ist eine ja kann man fast Programmiersprache schon. Also ist halt eine Sprache, womit in der Regel Webseiten gemacht werden. Also vor allem dynamische Webseiten, jetzt irgendwelche Shop Systeme oder Sachen, wo jetzt keine statischen Webseiten sind, sondern was sich zusammengebaut wird.
Ja, halt so eine Skript Sprache, die werden dann halt angestellt und müssen halt in sehr kurzer Zeit für sehr wenig Geld irgendwie die komplexesten Applikation zusammen hacken. Und das ist strange, also weil die schießen sich damit regelmäßig in die Füße. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich irgendwie so besonders.
Liegt es an der Programmiersprache oder an dem?
Also es gibt Sprachen, die sind anfälliger und es gibt Sprachen, die sind weniger anfälliger für solche Problematiken. Aber in erster Linie ist es natürlich der Programmierer selber, der sich wenig Gedanken um Nebeneffekte macht und Tja, Eingaben überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt, die er nicht erwartet. Also wenn ich dann halt mal so ein Hochkommereingebe, wo eigentlich eine Zahl stehen sollte oder so, dann kann es sein, dass eben da Nebeneffekte auftreten, die der Programmierer nicht bedacht hat. Und so kann man halt unter Umständen die Applikation nutzen, um weiter in das System einzudringen. Ich meine jetzt irgendwie so eine konkrete Anekdote, weiß ich nicht.
Gab es denn schon mal Fälle, die so krass waren, wo zum Beispiel so eklatant gegen irgendwelchen Datenschutz verstoßen wurde oder wo einfach so Sachen so krass waren, dass ihr gesagt habt, naja, die müssen wir jetzt eigentlich anzeigen. Also das ist eigentlich die Sache von Staatsanzeigen.
Anzeigen tut man sie nicht. Also klar, sowas habe ich halt auch schon gesehen. Also bei größeren Unternehmen, die zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit zur Verfügung stellen, sich online zu bewerben. Die Daten, die ein Bewerber da hoch lädt, wie Lebenslauf und Zeugnisse und Bewerbungen selber, die werden ja irgendwo gespeichert. Also sowas habe ich auch schon gesehen und das finde ich natürlich sehr krass, wenn die Unternehmen, die sowas bereitstellen, so eine Möglichkeit zur Onlinebewerbung eben nicht dafür Sorge tragen, dass das ausreichend gesichert ist. Das ist sehr krass. Also klar, das sind einmal so Bewerberdaten und auch ganz andere Sachen sieht man da. Also wie gesagt, ich meinte vorhin schon, dass man da regelmäßig Pferdekotzen sieht und dass man den Bewerberdaten sicherlich auch nur irgendwie so noch ziemlich unten.
Vielleicht zum Schluss, wir haben überlegt, wer ist eigentlich schuld an so einem Sicherheitslücken? Oder du hast gerade noch ein schönes Beispiel. Wer ist denn schuld an so einem Problem an Sicherheitslücken? Oder die Frage, wie kann man es besser machen? Oder wer ist jetzt in der Situation, wer hat den Hut auf? Wer ist verantwortlich in so einer Firma, in so einem Projekt, die Sachen besser zu machen, sicherer zu machen?
Also so ein Schuldpunkt gibt es eigentlich gar nicht, weil die Komplexität ist dermaßen groß, dass du nicht von irgendeiner Instanz irgendwo erwarten kannst, dass ihr das löst. Also du kannst nicht von deinem Systemadministrator erwarten, dass er alles sicher macht. Du kannst es nicht von deinem Hersteller erwarten, leider. Du kannst es nicht von deinen Programmierern erwarten. Also du kannst nicht da irgendein sagen, hier der ist schuld, weil der war jetzt gerade für den Co zuständig, der kaputt gegangen ist oder der ist jetzt für die Maschine zuständig, die kaputt gegangen ist. Das kannst du eigentlich nicht machen. Es ist schon sehr wichtig, irgendwie, dass man die Geschichten auch die Kirche mal im Dorf lässt und mal einfach schaut, OK, was habe ich denn wirklich für Bedrohungsszenarien? Weil du siehst nicht nur solche Sachen, wo Leute was sehr Wichtiges haben, was sie überhaupt nicht schützen, sondern siehst auch auf der anderen Sache. Leute, die irgendwie Sachen sich ganz genau angucken lassen. Und dann denkst du, wo ist jetzt genau das Problem? Ja, selbst wenn das jemand hackt, das ist doch eigentlich gar kein großes Thema. Und dann stellt man schon fest, dass eigentlich bloß ein bisschen im Auge behalten werden muss. Und du hast den großen Unternehmen eigentlich durch Außen Security Management. Und die müssen schon ihr Geschäft verstehen, ihre Bedrohungsszenarien verstehen.
Die müssen halt abwägen. Was ist jetzt wichtiger, ganz konkret, irgendwie die Sicherheit oder die Funktionalität? Oder was kann man erst mal hinten anstellen?
Würde es helfen, wenn sich die Firmen, also die Hersteller von Software beispielsweise mehr Zeit lassen würden, um diese Software zu bauen?
Das würde für viele Dinge helfen, auch für Funktionalität und nicht so kaputte Software.
Budget muss anders verteilt werden.
Würde das helfen, wenn die Softwarehersteller dann auch tatsächlich verantwortlich, sprich hafbar gemacht werden für die Fehler?
Das wäre sicherlich eine Motivation.
Ja, aber da kommst du in das Thema Haftung für Software und vor allem Gewährleistungsanspruch für Software. Und wenn wir damit anfangen, dann können wir die ganze Softwareindustrie zumachen und wieder von vorne anfangen, weil niemand hat irgendwelche Gewährleistungsmargen mit eingeplant. Also, dass er so Gewährleistungsfälle hat. Was denkst du, was mit einer Microsoft passiert wird, in dein Windows zurückschickst und alle anderen das auch tun? Also, das kann man fast abhaken.
Als erstes so stecken die mal in CDs. Ja, aber kannst du eine AOL-CD mit reintun. Würdet ihr euch das wünschen, dass einfach mal gesagt wird, okay, wir müssen das nochmal neu überdenken, also wie Software hergestellt wird, vielleicht tatsächlich mit so einer Gewährleistung rein?
Es ist unrealistisch, also das braucht man nicht wünschen. Ich fänd's super.
Ich wollte sagen, unrealistisch find ich's nicht. Also ich mein, wenn ein Auto, wenn da irgendwie ein Fehler ist, das ist irgendwie die Hölle für den Hersteller, der muss dann halt irgendwie eine Million Autos zurückrufen. So what? Dann bei Software, na gut, die müssen halt Patches schicken, machen viele Firmen ja auch, wenn sie eine Fehler, eine Lücke haben, aber vielleicht muss der Druck da ein bisschen größer werden.
Vielen Dank, das war Chaosradio 102, Traumberuf Hacker? Fragezeichen war das Thema der Sendung heute Abend.
Ist das ein Traumbuch, noch mal abschließend, kurzes Ja, Nein?
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall einen sehr, sehr spannenden Job und habe sehr viel Spaß dabei.
Zwei Security Consultants hatten wir hier, nämlich Thorsten und Felix, vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Chaosradio 103 gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Juni, was der neunundzwanzigste sein müsste, wenn ich mich nicht so richtig täusche. Und das nächste, was wir machen wollen, das ist, wir wollen ins FEDS in der Wohlheide gehen oder ins FIZ in der Wohlheide zu Berlin 05 vom 10. bis 12.6. für 15 Euro, drei Tage lang Musik und Workshops, unter anderem mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Wenn ihr wissen wollt, worum es da geht, Berlin 05 ccc.de. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Gute Nacht. Ich heiße Robert Klein, aber das tut relativ wenig zur Sache. Ich wusste, ich hatte noch was vergessen und zwar anzukündigen, dass hier der Night Flight wie jeden Donnerstag mit Martin Petersdorf stattfinden wird ab 1.